English Subtitles by Alen Alic
-
Welcome H3 warriors! Today we go to war!
Who what do we go to war against?
What are we going to war? My cursor is a micro transaction in video games video. Oh, we're going to war against me
No, no micro transactions in vain' ok and youtube you had mentioned. I'm so mad right now today we go to war over
microtransactions and and youtube and
Thank you - stamps calm and me undies
Our guest today if you couldn't tell is the wonderful
Boogie2988 a lot of people may not be able to tell because I look like a complete in person
I mean besides losing now 250 pounds. Mm-hmm
150 since the surgery
Then I got the brand new teeth. Hi, which is really weird because I'm still getting used to this
This is three weeks. I've had these teeth and
And I don't know I change frames and it was like you look like a hipster now
I'm like, I just trying to look like GAMEOVER Greggy if the depression finally one for game over Greg
I want to look like Greg Miller as if like, he just gave up. That's what I was looking for work. Well you really have
Transformed and I love that you regularly come and check in with us because yeah from the first time this is your third time on
The show now. I'm the finally three timers you have I'm like, oh actually you may be the first three time
Well, thank you happy. Yeah, I mean, I love having you you're one of the best guess ever. Yeah for the first
Time you came in here you were with your now ex-wife
Hmm and you could not enter unassisted right you were I remember you want such excruciating pain?
I just might honestly it felt so horrible for you. Like just seeing you go down
I wasn't trying to go out you had to exit and take a break
Now - now looking at you
You told me you were just walking around Universal for
Like five miles a universal another mile around
Hollywood that night and so six miles in a day and a little sore from it have some blisters
Well, I would be telling ya I realized at home by the way, you're dealing with my now Lisp. It's temporary. Mighty
I'm just getting used to my new teeth. I'm only three weeks out
So if you can tell my voice has changed a little bit
It's going to get better if I don't really notice that much but I understand you it's probably more noticeably conscience
But you just got new brand new teeth three weeks ago
Why did you need T. I mean, I know why did you need new? Teeth? What did they pull all your teeth out?
Like he tell me it's over like hereditarily
my family has
The worst teeth and my mom and my dad wearing dentures by 40 and I probably needed to be in dentures by 40
My brother has struggled us alive for the implants to stop
my sister has very like she lost all her teeth and had to get stuff early on in their 20s, so
I had just had this fatalistic attitude about my teeth one day
I will get dentures and not just won't worry about it, and I definitely didn't record
You don't have dentures you have like no. These are my employee. That's the real deal g4
Buy gulp accom are the people that did it and they have like a cutting-edge technology
They call the the the g4 system and basically they they screw metal posts. They pulled all my teeth only at 17 teeth left
I don't know how many - oh wow. That's
14 were infected. I was walking around 14 rampant infections of your mouth. He's saying all the time all the
Day after surgery. I was in less pain than I was the day before and that's after them cutting me wide open, right?
so they remove all the teeth and they cut open the gums and they go in and they they shape the bone and
then they put in metal posts and
I'm like half conscious during all this like I if you watch the video on my youtube channel youtube.com slash Brookings donate
Typing boogie teeth and you'll see this video even show where they spliced me open. Just put in the metal teeth
But I was so awake. They're like give me a thumbs up and I'm like because I was conscious but I don't remember it
Why don't they keep you conscious they wanted to make sure that I could answer
Commands and stuff when we need to open her mouth we need you know
We need you to set up they need you to be a new writer, but they also give you like a twilight drug
So you don't have to remember any of it, so I don't
And it gave me some painkillers too obviously right now, yeah, but they put in these metal posts
Yeah
that skull screw in your skull and then screw into your
jawbone
and then they put bridges that are then screwed onto those metal screws and
I can I can go to them and they'll take these out and they can clean them and I have to do that
at least once a year and
Ordeal, they don't take them out. Yeah, just one screw up and and I can't do it at home
Right because it's the special tools and stuff. But at the bridge you ever broke or anything and so a lot of people realize this
The guns the gums look hella healthy and their prosthetic as well
Yeah, look at that
Natural right, but if you really really seein you can see where they need my actual guns, right?
Closely I can't yeah
I feel like I mean the internet seems to keep telling me that the upper row is a little too big but I like them
Right that what do they mean the top like maybe the top two teeth are a little too big for my face or something
but I like it and so this is one of those instances where
The Internet has been kind of mean a lot of people mostly supportive, right?
some people are like
Oh, you look like spongebob and that one episode or you look like the guy from the two fairy godmothers or what?
Here's the fuck you okay? No one fuck you. All right, I didn't do this for you. I don't care if you like it
I do this for me. I wanted to get out of pain. I wanted to get out of infection I wanted
To look a little better. Sure. I'm human
I don't really care how I look but I care about not hurting all the time
And the other reason I did is because the company that's doing this they agreed to give away
To people who are in need of for real 12 surgeries over the next year
So they just announced that if you go to g4 by global com, I think it's like a sub site
I'm not sure it's linked on the web main website
But if you search for it
they want people to submit like stories and videos and pictures and
They let me pick 12 people and do the surgery it really really light and what he changed it for me, right?
It's like it's a life-changing thing. Right and it's unbelievable
Well, I told them if somebody comes in and mentions my name I want to talk every person that comes into my sister's name
right
so we had the first person come in that mentioned seeing my video and I've been like
Texting him back and forth
then he got his teeth two days ago and like
Just coaching him through it and like the healing procedure and because my healing procedure was atypical
Because I'm a youtuber and I know that sounds weird you mean because you have to show your mouth
Well, not only that but because I they told me go home and talk as much as you need to
Because you're gonna need to learn how to speak and eat soft foods for the first couple of weeks
But you can eat some rougher stuff. You're gonna be fine like you salad. Don't worry about it. Be some broccoli. You'll be fine
avoid nuts for now, right and
A week after the surgery. I started bleeding. Hmm. I was doing a pique woodysgamertag
His podcast and I started bleeding and so I called my doctor and I'm like doc
What's happening? It goes you maybe you've ruptured one of the stitches. Have you been eating a lot? I'm like doc
I'm a fat guy
Yes, I've been eating a lot of eating soft foods because like are you talking a lot?
And I'm like, no, I'm barely talking
I did a four hour podcast today
Filmed a YouTube video that took of our talking and then I screamed on my twitch channel for three hours
I barely talked for eight hours today and he's like shut the fuck up and sat down
Because you're you're causing your mouth to bleed because no one talks for eight hours. What are you doing? Why are you doing this?
What's my job?
And so, uh, I bled for like three days straight
Like just like like a little bit it was like a lot when it's coming out of your mouth because it mixes a salon. Yeah
And so like on the third day I messaged him and I'm like, hey doc. I've been bleeding for three days
Should I be worried? He's like Steve half the population bleeds for three days woman up. Okay, so you're gonna be fine, right?
Oh my god, woman up. Yeah, he's a woman of because half the population literally bleeds for three
Kind of week here, huh? Yeah, but I think if woman were bleeding from the mouth, they'd be more concerned too
You know, I always worry about a lot blood loss and everything else, but he's like no you're fine
He is is a lot. He's got patients bleeding up from their mouths. He's like well, no. No, baby
He said it's the only time that's ever happened. That's exactly time
Anybody has talked himself out of huh out of the recovery. You know, how much does that?
that
Procedure cost he's expensive. Yeah gaveling Medicare it can I think it comes in like eleven thousand?
My surgery would have been thirty eight thousand thirty thousand that is restrict, right? But I mean, it's so good
It's so life-changing what man that's it's implants for like five thousand dollars a tooth
And so if you need 32 teeth replace like oh that's way more expensive like it's a hundred and fifty thousand or something. Yeah
This procedure is cutting-edge. It's been done like ten thousand times
I think now he's done it and there's like the all on system and then there's the g4 system
What's like what's cutting-edge about it? Like it's a much faster turnaround. It's easier and a lot less expensive than the other options
And so I was really surprised really glad to do it. But the reason I did is because Jake the snake Roberts
I've talked to him like once Diamond Dallas Page mean him or friends
And Jake got the procedure done and it went viral and like a lot of you know
I so that's why I reached out of the company. I'm like, please help me
I will proselytize I will go on the h3 podcast and will tell everybody that's listening there
that you guys offer this service because I know
There's a lot of people other but when they agreed to do it for like 12 other people
How do you not do it for even if I didn't want to do it at that point? I we can do it
I don't want some new origin
Record, you know that there's people in Hollywood and I and I'm almost sure this is true who have teeth like mine that are fine
But not like extraordinarily beautiful or anything and they'll get these motherfuckers yanked and gets beautiful brand new teeth in or veneers
I was talking to you I swear bro there
Why is it that everyone probably is walking through it unless you needed to medically because you have like beautiful
Perfect one procedure for sure. Um, it was far. It was not great the first 24 hours. It's not great
The first week was not great
But after the first week, I was in less far less pain than I was any other point with my teeth problems, bro
Do you think that getting fake titties is pleasant they do they get fake asses
Kim Kardashian has like two cabbages in her an ass right the Abbi
Do you have you seen I'm telling you like I guess I just we gotta find pictures of like celebrities with like
Ridiculously perfect teeth you can almost tell when their faith I always wonder Jim Carrey Steve or fake cuz there Jim Carrey listen come up
You ought to bring up you ought to bring up a before picture of my teeth because there's a hug. They're so bad
Looks like the broken picket fence around my gym bag
This cord of uh, it's got some pictures of some
Celebs that have done it. Yeah. Oh we got celebs. They've done it. This is what I'm into. This is what and you're right
I mean the second one down is Hilary Duff and they have before and after well, we're fine. Really what?
I don't know what's going on. No, that's not real scroll down one though fucking down. The second one is very obvious
The Duff
Yeah, bro, well, you know, I'm not convinced about that one either
Here's that here's what I will tell you people treat you different when you do this Israel
I'm so weird the Clooney but then you can kind of see like what is going on
Like did you see what I'm saying? You look like white what is with these beautiful?
Perfect teeth that they have like I know it so Americans are obsessed. They are
Okay, get a load of this
I think that's why I'm so shocked that anyone would do it unless they had to like medically well think about
When I think about this
it's normal to put
Braces on kids because there's teeth need to be straightened for right? I mean that's so straight-up cosmetic surgery, right?
It's crazy, but you'd like you just said people treat
On the way back. Well, yeah from surgery. I noticed for the first time
I was going through the airport and every time I've ever gone to like the airport the girl behind the counter does this she's like
Hello, sir. Mmhmm. Yeah, are you going you have your ID and
The very first person I interacted with after surgery. She's like hi sir. How are you today?
Yes
Do you have your ID like?
Direct and high contact the whole time and I stopped to get a sandwich and the guy behind the counter is like hi
How are you? They surfing I'm like
Are people really the shallow? Does it make no, I don't give I don't think it's shallow. I think that you almost
You just wanted to avert your gaze because you don't want to stare or be rude or something
I think I don't think that it's like oh, he's so hideous. I can't look at him, right?
I just think that it's like
because I do that saying I do that same thing with attractive people to I'm like I have to stare directly in your eyes and
Because I don't want to look at those delicious man boobs you have
That right back yeah
But what do you mean? That's a cosmetic surgery? Absolutely. Yeah, but do you see what I'm saying?
Like it does make a diff like she's got these celebrities. They have to be perfect. Right, right
They got the fake ass they got the fake tits. Let's get some fake teeth in there, too
I guess if it'd make you if it makes you feel better about yourself, I'm not one to judge but wait
This is a love song if it makes you happy
Look at that beautiful day
Yeah, you're an exclusive club now bugs. Oh hell. Yeah, Chris Rock
Look, I'm telling you his teeth are great before but there's there's a bunch of gaps. Yeah. Thank you. God adds personality
I agree, but they disagree with you her chill my other mother fYI. They get wooden teeth back in
Look
Perfect now friend of the show. Yeah, he's a friend
So there you have it I'm telling you I love this man 50 cent look at that beautiful smile
oh, that's a smart call but like
Some people get just veneers as well. Right like you're right Jim Carrey. Apparently Oh
A chipped tooth. Come on. Get out of here with this. Yeah. Yeah. Look at that beautiful teeth. Oh, that's perfect, right
Yeah, I didn't want mine to be - okay, so I asked for one dollar please. I didn't wanted to be perfectly even
You know ya know I feel you can't go right. I don't want to be greedy
All right
so I want I ask for longer canines and I jokingly said can I get vampire teeth and it's like yeah, I like what
He's like I didn't get them
It looks normal, but he's like if you want if you want weird teeth you come back in here with some money
We'll make whatever crazy people you want. We don't care. Yeah, if I was you're gonna be like trust me you do not
That one like giant werewolf. Bring teeth or something. I don't know I go like get a guerrilla
I guess I can make me a grill now sure, except it wouldn't be a grill over these prosthetic teeth. We have a
Grill, man, that's crazy. What is the maintenance like it's a pain in the ass. So number one
Obviously, this is my teeth were rotting out. I didn't have a very good maintenance routine
I did mouthwash twice a day and I was done brush ya know cuz it hurt the brush. I was painful. It was excruciating
I would bleed every time I tried to brush, you know, I had like 17 toughen tanned teeth anyway
But like can you imagine when you have an infection taking a toothbrush over it is miserable
So just hit mouthwash two or three times a day now. I've got a brush after every meal
I have to my mouth out with mouthwash after every meal
I have to floss but you don't floss between the teeth because there is no gap between these people
The gap is between the gums and the bridge
I have to start off with
water pick that make sure there's nothing under there and then I have to take
Those right and actually I'm not flossing the bridge. I'm flossing the metal posts
Those metal posts built there's market. I was wondering there's no gap. Yeah. Yeah, it's pain in the ass. Yeah, that's pretty intense. Yeah
It's a pain in the ass, but it's worth it
I mean once you have to keep this nice, I'm gonna take care of for the rest of my life
I'm so excited to have them right? Yeah. I had nice teeth growing up. I might have taken care of them
Mm-hm, but it's been it's been really weird like like you mentioned the the start of the podcast the ability to walk this morning
I woke up and
Had another crater one of the bright a lunch before I came to the show. I'm like, okay
Where do you want to meet?
So we walked for two and a half blocks and I didn't think about it
And I'm like sore I had blisters on my feet from universal. Yeah, but yeah, it's it's it's very
Freeing because I had to do right after the show last year. I had to do physical therapy. Mmm
And there I think maybe just before actually and they they were telling me you have to learn how to walk again
You're still walking like a 600 pound got your swaddling, right?
We have to teach you everything how to walk how to sit how to be in your new body. Mm-hmm
and now that I've done that I've gone cave exploring a couple times I've
Hiked the mountain in Colorado. I only made it like halfway up
I might like two miles up but still be able to do that
And I think I can make it at the top of that mountain now
It's just I know it's very freeing. Yeah, I can imagine
I mean it's fascinating because I I feel like there's obviously the first time I came here
I felt like I was gonna die like that right? I never thought I would dig Muro
I didn't think you had long to live
I mean you were you
Did not I mean man you you couldn't even make it down the stairs you had to sit down and catch your breath
Oh, that's very dimensional
Yeah
I really was I
Was in so much pain that too because we're doing VidCon and we were traveling and I injured my back a little bit that day
So I remember you told me you were on the ground
Just in pain you could do your back bones so bad and so as your pain in your joints in your back and everything
Getting my teeth out maybe huge difference for my back pain. I can't believe it. But he's like, oh, I'm a constantly, uh,
College and it's all connected, right?
And so I was out of like a for everyday when I woke up before the teep getting taken out three weeks ago now three
Weeks later. I'm at a one when I wake up. I'm not even taking my pain medication right? I'm credible
I'm just like I just get up and move. It's I can't congratulate. Yeah. Yeah, that's a beautiful
So I'm curious to see where I'm gonna be this time that's here. The Internet is convinced. I'm not gonna get fat again
Yeah, and like I'm gonna reverse the process
but I I'm so motivated by not do that because life is yet Internet is truly a collection of the very
Most I li. Yeah. Yeah, you're not right. You're not running like I don't know
It's like George Carlin said I don't insult any viewers out there obviously, right?
Go ahead in Salt Lake George
Do it George Carlin once said think of someone
you know of average intelligence and not
Average intelligence for your sprint circle with actual average nouns and then remember half the world's dumber than that motherfucker. Yeah
That's a great loss
Like I think there's a lot of smart people out there who are purposely obtuse and purposely but they don't listen to this show
right, of course the only the smart most
But I will say some of those idiots see clips from the show and they're like, let's use this as a weapon, you know
Let's take a quick break
When I come back, I want to talk about the blowback you got from the last time he came
Oh, yeah, that was fairly you had some you had some issues. I didn't really follow it. I had a great time. I thought I
was I just thought it was one of the best and I went off and did the rest of VidCon and then I made the
mistake of checking Twitter at one point
I was like, oh my guy like death threats had people like calling for my blood the end of my career
I'm like, okay. Well, let's get into that. I'm curious cuz I don't know what you said. So let's take a quick break guys
We'll be right back and we will find out why there's a bounty on know they're looking right there. Probably is
Yeah, the man no, no, let's be right back
No one's got time to go to the post office, you're busy I'm busy we're all busy
Okay, the post office is a pain in the butt
That's why you need stamps calm the most popular time-saving tool for small businesses and individuals that just liked us and stuff in the mail
Sam saw comm eliminates trips to the post office and saves you time and money with discounts that you couldn't even get at the post
Office stamps comm brings all the amazing services of the u.s
post office right to your computer
Whether your small office sending invoices or an online
Sellers shipping out products or just a sweet young grandchild who's sending birthday cards to his grandma?
Even a warehouse sending thousands of packages a day stamps.com can handle it with ease simply use your computer to print official US postage
24/7 for any letter any
Package any class of mail anywhere you want to send once your mail is ready
You just hand it to your mail carrier or drop it in a mailbox. It's really that simple
With Sam's comm you get five cents off every first-class stamp at up to 40% off Priority Mail not to mention
It's a fraction of the cost of those expensive postage meters
I don't know. What postage Mainers are but I guess if you're someone who knows what it is, you know what it is
Sam's do you know what I mean? Like you either know where you don't Sam comm is a no-brainer saving you time and money
It's no wonder over 700,000 small businesses or to use stamps comm listen to this offer
This is a good one right now
our listeners get a special offer that includes a four week trial plus free postage and
a digital scale without any long-term commitment
Free postage just like free money go to stamps calm that's literally free money, you know, you can buy shit with stamps
They say it's legally money. Is that right then?
Let's go stand. I don't don't try that
But something I've heard go to stamps calm click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type. H3
That stamps comm go to the microphone enter. H3. If you want some free postage scales the whole shebang convenience everything Samsung Co
Did you that you spent
Did you know that the average person?
spends 90% of their life and underwear
No my case a hundred percent because I have a phobia and I don't like taking my dick out ever
Like when me and when we conceived I was wearing boxers, but just get took it out of the hole, right?
so in my case a hundred percent and then so that means it's
Really important that I'm in the most comfortable underwear that I could possibly find on the market
That's why I like to introduce you guys to me undies. It's made of micro modal. It's soft as hell. It's breathable
It's gonna change your life because a lot of us walk around these cheap package underwear that's chafing
It's an it's a all over the place. You have too much freedom. Let's say in some cases. You have not enough
That's what me undies innovates. It's soft its flexible its breathable. It has it all
you didn't know that underwear could be this comfortable until you put
It's in size give it a shot you got nothing to lose here. Okay. It's so soft. It's three times softer than cotton
You're gonna feel like you're being hugged
by joy itself and you got multiple styles for
women men and
women making out try new boxer briefs with a fly what an innovation which is some of the great cut as boxer briefs now and
Added option for guys who prefer to go through the gate first over the fence that way
There's a third option that many people don't know about you can go down the leg hole just a third option
The tunnel down the tunnel through the tunnel sure
The man DS is also go-to for the softest loungewear on the planet hang out in their supply comfy lounge pants and onesies
Yes, man, these makes onesies and they're incredible
So here's where basically you've nothing to lose mandis has a great offer for my listeners for any
First-time purchaser when you get any my undies you get 15% off and free shipping
Get 50% off a pair of the most comfortable undies you will ever put on and there's a hundred percent satisfaction guaranteed
So if you don't like it, boom send it back. They don't Center in it. They're burn it and you get your money back
So it's a goddamn we went
15% off your first pair of free shipping 100% satisfaction guaranteed go to Mandy's comm /h tree. That's me. Andy's calm /h of the
Welcome back. We are here with year boy a boogie
And we've got the tensions explained. So you're in the hot seat now. I destroy my career on this part
Yes, so used to say that but obviously you're here. You're back. You're good. Good go. I love your aunties
No, but you didn't really destroy I know if can feel like that
I'll plan we've all kind of we've all kind of felt that times
But do you really think that you nearly destroyed your career last time you're on here? Um well and specifically what topic
Okay, so we were talking about like the lbgtq community and I said something very stupid
I don't want to repeat what I said cuz it was really stupid. Um, okay. I don't remember what you said
No
it was I was talking about like same-sex marriage and how the Supreme Court ratified it really quickly and how
the world like reacted very poorly to that and I my intention was to say that
I I hate that people are getting killed over the shit and I wish that we had a way for people not get killed
The way I said, it was very stupid basically, but that was my intention
I don't I hate that people are killing each other in the streets and I just don't want that to happen, right and
Because that people took it out of context and they ignored the intention and then it was it was miserable. So
Okay, so it was just that one statement about and that's right. What's the big one? That was the biggest?
I thought it was about like something else cuz that I didn't we were talking about all kinds of wonderful things like feeder
you had a expression that I
Was on the show
Yeah, if I'm being honest, I was in a complete mental breakdown
I was in the middle of a complete mental breakdown the last year of my life last two years of my life
since the gastric bypass surgery almost two years ago has been both the
best year of my life because of my recovery and the worst year of my life because of the changes I've gone through and the
negative and attention
I'm getting on the Internet and like who gets here's a story they gave you an example of how rough my life has been I
Don't want to play the victim or anything like that
But my ex-wife and I agreed to separate two months after my gastric bypass surgery
Right and we didn't make it public until like four months after my gastric bypass surgery. So I go to the one-year meeting with my
surgeon who did my gastric bypass
and I'm
depressed because I started off at
550 ish right? My biggest error was 587 I
Go into the office and I'm like 380. Mmm at the one-year mark, and now I'm like 340
But at 380 I felt defeated because I expected to do so much more till a lot of it was right
117 what did you expect? I mean, what did I want it to be? Well, that's the thing
So I tell the doctor how frustrated I am. How mad I am and he's like Steve
I want to show you a chart and he pulls out of Chardon. He says you've lost
50% of your excess body weight. Mm-hmm at the one-year mark. Now that the here's your chart here's where you charted here is
The national average for people get the surgery you're exactly on cue you have lost exactly
50 percent of your excess body weight after one year. That's what everybody does your average and I'm like
But I didn't want to be average done. Yeah, I wanted to be exceptional
I've got a lot of people watching a lot of people counting on me and I wanted to do better and he goes
But do you don't have any idea how many of my patients go through a divorce in the first three months of?
A Hesus if I'm being entirely honest with you
We watched your videos in the audience in the office and when you announced that you were getting divorced
We didn't think you were gonna lose any more weight. We thought you were gonna stop it like four thirty four twenty
Mmm, now here you are 380 and you're still losing. Yeah, and the window hasn't closed. You still have plenty of chances to lose weight
You are the exception. I've never had a patient go through a we have plenty of divorces because it's very common with this procedure
But never two months after the surgery that's never happened Plus lest you are here
You spoke very highly of your ex-wife and I still will you guys are very?
Honorable, we're still friends. I've talked to her most of the time. I've been here. We've been trading pictures back and forth. We're still friendly
Just really the timing though. Yeah, we just we didn't worse when we we just yeah
And we just didn't work and she had things that she wanted to go do and things that I needed to go do and God
Loved her. Here's the thing. She could have easily left before that surgery and I would have never gotten it
She would have been leaving me for dead. She stuck around through the surgery. She stuck around through the recovery
I wasn't fully recovered, but I stop bleeding for the most part. I I was able to take some care of myself
She left me in good hands with my best friend of my roommate, you know?
And he stayed like an extra month after we agreed to separate just to make sure I was okay, right? That is very nice
She said she's a good person. I'm still you know, I probably the love of my life, honestly
I don't know that I'll ever love anybody the way I loved her and and Dom's like you still have
when you say that, that makes me wonder if you
See down the road
Some kind of reconciliation or relation
If I'm being entirely
Brutally honest and I feel no reason not to you know
This is one of those moments where my brains like don't say it
but I'm gonna say it if I'm entirely brutally honest we didn't work and we weren't happy and I
don't see us ever working because we just don't have the matching personality types and
She said something to me on the way out the door that I'll never forget
she's like I told her I'm like
I'll never get remarried after this and she's like
You're already married and I'm like I know but we're getting a divorce because that's not I'm talking about you're married to this job
She's cool. It's all you do
Even when you couldn't do anything else you're in front of this computer 12 hours a day
Working on YouTube working on streaming working on phone calls working on brand deals. It's all you do. Isn't that a little unfair though?
Because I mean that is how you guys met right? Well, yeah, we met through YouTube. Yeah, but she's not wrong, right?
I mean, you know, and so that's been my focus in the last year
I started dating I talked about last time I was on the show. I started dating and doing the whole youtuber thing
Like hey, I've got money and hey, I'm kind of famous and hey
I can meet a lot of girls and then that got really boring after like six months or so and
It went wrong a few times
I'm like I met a lot of robbery unsavory people like girls who would like who are in it for the money
I like asked for money. Right would they ask you for like hey, can you help me with rent?
And here's the kinda look for hunter bucks for run Oh for real. All right, I'm like no
Like of course not like this is where this is not prostitution. We're we're dating right a good dealer process, right?
That's a good deal. Yeah, especially some of the girls that I got to go out
But eventually I realized that I don't think I'm meeting
anybody with good intentions any time soon fare and then don't get wrong if you're a
Sugar baby out there. If you're a gold digger, you're a sex worker. I got nothing but love and respect for you
She's not something that I necessarily need a mile for the time
Yeah right now right you you need you need emotional you need nurturing bingo, right?
And so, you know, that's what I was looking for is an emotional relationship not a physical one
It was nice having a physical relationship. I didn't get to do that in college
so it was nice to do that post divorce, but now I guess eight months of just
Not really looking or not. You haven't been
Romantically involved or I really I've had a few dates just like hey, do you want to go see in game with me?
All right, let's go same game. Yeah, you know or let's let's you I like you to ruse Chris. You're cute
Do you want to eat a roost Chris tonight?
And then sometimes we make it back to my house and sometimes we don't it's mostly just about the experience and sharing with somebody pretty
But never am I I'm not even considering an emotional relationship
Because I want to work on my business and I want to work on my body
And when I get to the weight that I'm at when I get the way that I want to look when I've got the money
in the bank that I want to have then I'll start looking for somebody and as it is right now it's just
Making how much money do you need in a bank to get it took?
You know, you look it you don't got to pull off so much. I want a theorem to go through the roof because
Once I have fuck-you money
Now I'm still gonna do YouTube. It's going to do it difference. So what are y'all friends? Let us you money in your mind
I would like to have I'd like to have a solid cleared
One point five million and I'm not tied up into my house not tied up in the cars and I'll tie it up into anything
else
I have one point five million dollars liquid that I can invest and put wherever I want it make me more money when I have
That kind of money. I will be so Arkansas rich. I'll never
Tell anybody in the state except the Waltons of course, right?
Arkansas rich, I love that. Yeah, 1.5 million doesn't get you very far
No, it does not but in Arkansas it gets you off like ten houses
Because I bought my dream home there for like a quarter million and then they're in the divorce
We had to change ownership and everything. So we had to get reevaluated and I got to re-evaluate at 310
I've owned it for years. So my house it was like 270 is what we bought it for announced for 310
Yeah, so I bless for a right. What are you making money? Yeah living in it. My mortgage is only 1500
1500 month yeah off of a 15-year mortgage. Yeah saying yeah, that's really good
So III think eventually I'm just gonna become a well. I think he's more out there and buy all the house. Yeah, absolutely
Thrown like a block and this is my blocking this absolutely set up centuries and barbed wire fence, right?
Powered events real-life tower fence right be ready with Amin, but that's the that's the thing when it when I get to that point
It's just gonna the only thing I'm really change. I think I would I want to do YouTube
Yeah, I would have thought that you would have already had some more close to that already. Well I did get divorced
Yeah, you know that you lose half. Yeah, right
but a lot of people always think I made one even I did but you remember
YouTube at the beginning the view numbers were low even though the pay was I right
Yeah, and I've only ever I'm still working on my billionth of view
I still haven't had my billion view tube, even right and had revenue for me. I've always been on Adsense
I've never been with an MCN. So I've always had the lowest possible ad rates off of Adsense
And then I've never been really
Brand friendly on top of that because the Francis video isn't breaking stuff and destroying stuff and smashing stuff
So it's been hard to get brains to work with and I've really changed that in the last three years
Yeah, but most of the money that was offered to me would be video game companies, right?
Mmm, and hey, let's fly you out and we'll give you some money review our game
I'm not taking money to review a game on what planet well, then don't review it. Just talk about it. Okay, but that's a lie
Right. Well, I did that once really I actually did that once with the Ubisoft game. Ooh
Ubisoft well I have for
It was a
Assassin's Creed the one that had multiplayer and right and they like
Booked the flights. We booked the tickets
we booked the hotel and
We want you to come out and play it and so they had two rounds of
Influencer showing up and one of my friends showed up for the first round your phone. Sorry
I'm sorry buggy following issues here. I swear to God I viewed it fuck
Unbelievable or slap you right in the Fupa? Yeah. No, but
Ubisoft the the Assassin's Creed game with the multiplayer in it
Even they booked the tickets the the booked the flights that booked the hotel the whole nine yards. I pay you
Yeah, a little bit like spending money. Okay, and
Just just a cover of meals and shit, right?
Yeah, and so I'm ready to go out and play the game and experience it and they want you give an honest review
Right, but I don't know how I feel about flying out to play a game now
I do because I just trashed Mortal Kombat 11 for its microtransactions, even though they flew me out for the reveal for that, right?
But at the time I was new and I was nervous and I didn't know how it feel about trashing a game
I got a trip for right
Yeah
so they had two rounds of influencers and my friend did the first round and she calls me and she's like
Do not show up and like watch you guys. It's a shit show. Hmm
It's miserable III screen for two or we film for two hours. I got 15 minutes of usable footage
It's it's a fit show about it
The multiplayer aspect was poorly coded just saying the game itself was bad, right and I'm like, oh, that's juicy. Nonetheless, right?
I'm like I then I'm definitely not going to show up and I I called my company that was
arranging everything and I'm like, hey, I'm feeling a little ill and I'm also feeling uncomfortable about the deal and they're like
You know
You have a back out clause where we you agree to pay us if you back out from this and I'm like well
I don't agree to pay you and I know I signed a piece of paper
But I'm never paying you and I'll never work with you again
If you try to make me and they're like, alright, we're sorry. Why don't you just show up and give it a shitty review?
Cuz I didn't want to take a big dump on the developers
I don't mind taking a dump on a CEO right like the CEO of epic Tim Sweeney
I'll go far out and ahem Sweeney all day
Right, but I don't want I don't want to take a dump on the developers who work on fortnight
I don't want to take a dump on the people who are working on the storefront in epic
The people Tim Sweeney hires Tim Sweeney's making decisions Tim Sweeney bonuses, right? Yeah by pushing out an uncomplete game
That's not on the developer. Right? Right. It's never on the developer
It's always on the guy who gets that twenty million dollar bonus at Activision. Yeah, it's always on that it Bobby Connick
It's always I'm part economy
So I will I will bully Bobby Kotick all day
But I will not bully a single person that works under Bobby Kotik because why would I see it's he's under the pay grade
If you get a 20 million dollar bonus, you're damn, right?
I'm gonna talk shit about you on the other
and so when you
Didn't show up was there beef with?
Ubisoft they are actually really cool about it because I think they understood that the state of the game, but they
All come right. It's probably it. Right, right
Actually the whole things off, but then like Ed Boon flew me out to play Mortal Kombat 11
And I will tell you right now I the gameplay loop for Mortal Kombat 11
I love if you go to the story mode
If you go to the the local fighting or the online fighting you will never notice the microtransactions
They're just not built into the game in a way that annoys you right?
but if you go to the towers of time, or if you go to the Crypt or if you go to the customization
It's right there in your face and looks of course I have to complain about that
Right and I feel so bad because I love Ed Boon and I love the Mortal Kombat game loop
And I love the entire franchise and I got the flower to play the game
but of course I'm making a video talking about that you have to write like it if I don't have my
Integrity on YouTube then. What do I have that we live and die by our integrity, right?
So I felt super bad, but I'm like trashing Ed's game, you know, it's worth buying if you like the gameplay loop
But they should never deal with it with him Dylan microtransactions
And there's something else that really bothered me about Mortal Kombat 11
And this is I think this will be the viral clip that makes Twitter mad at me. So
Get ready everybody buckle up, but I'm playing through Mortal Kombat 11
and I'm playing the story mode and at one point Shao Kahn says
Actually to me, honestly, I don't remember him saying it personally experiencing it. I've seen other people talk about it, though
I think it is in story mode. It might be in like one of his lines. So you haven't seen it. You've seen a clevy
People talking about I've seen people talk about it. Uh-huh, but I didn't pay that much attention to the story mode
I just wanted the rewards. I mean hear about the story. I skipped it through a lot
But at some point apparently Shao Kahn the big bad of the Mortal Kombat series
says
Make Outland great again. That's why I'm wearing the shirt. I'm wearing today. This is my most political shirt. Yeah, soren
Running for yeah, that's a bad. That's a bad take
on great again, right so
Our make middle-earth right good again, right maybe Mordor
that's a bad, but
so you have
Shao Kahn emulating Donald Trump and all I can think is some to play Mortal Kombat 11
It's like can I play one game without remembering one apocalyptic statement that's there?
I think it's almost a prism left guy samus gave me Mortal Kombat 11 used to be all escapism Mortal Kombat is escapism
Yeah, right, you're literally ripping people's tits off and feeding him to them, right?
Like that's the entire point of the game is to escape reality. Yeah, and
And now I have to I don't want can I not think about Donald Trump for like a day?
Is that a thing I could do not because I thought no you can I'm a huge Stephen King fan. Love Stephen King
I fought Stephen King on Twitter twelve years ago when he created his tweeter Twitter
Right, and I created mine and he would talk about its books and to talk about his family and talk about it
These families books and we talked about like the movies
They were making a lot of falling Stephen King. And now all Stephen King does his tweet about Donald Trump
Ten times a day 20 times a day 30 times a day, and I don't disagree
I do not disagree with a single thing that Stephen King has to say about all from
But can we talk about your books? Can you write a book man? Can you make a movie?
Can we have 12 minutes where I'm scared of a fucking monster again? That's not a living actual monster in this country
Stephen King would probably say that
He
It's probably just what's up, you know, what's in his brain, you know
just the way he's they and let's I mean Donald Trump is the king of
Getting attention, of course, right? Like he's he loves all the more reason to not give him the attention
But yeah, I agree with you. I I
Have found myself
Like I used to be fan of the late night shows the Fallon's the Jimmy's and all the Jimmy is not the Jim not all
The Jimmy's the Kimbell the Kimball's and it's like, you know, especially Colbert's
unwatchable now like I was a big fan of The Colbert Report and
He's just I look at him and I still watch because there's nothing to watch ever on television. I wonder every night
I wonder to myself why the fuck am I paying for dish raaah?
Hey, it's so expensive for so many commercials and there's never anything to watch
That being said I look at Colbert and I'm like this hack
It's all he talks about is Donald Trump's exhaustion
And I and I hate how he just assumes that everyone who watches a show like as on his page
you know where he's like, well Donald Trump's the biggest fucking loser in the world and everyone's like
Right, right. It's like well, I know a lot of Trump supporters and that's weird, right?
Not very many in Arkansas because there's very few and where I live in Arkansas. Hmm
But a lot of people where I grew up in Virginia, mm-hm and most of them do not like Donald Trump
They do not like him as a person they do not like his politics what they voted for
They wanted the coal mines to reopen
They wanted him to
try to bring business back to
Like jobs to America and that's why they voted for him and they'll vote for him again because they hope that's what happened
He's gonna get him right? You can't explain to him. You can't
Yeah, I joke about being super Idol on stream all the time and people are like why I'm like, dude
I don't live through a second trump presidency. It's not like it's not even really Trump's like I don't like the trumpet's policy
I see a stereo going on a nation. I can't handle it, you know
Besides of whoever whatever you think about Trump. I'll go on the record and say that he's not my guy, right?
He's definitely not my guy. He's not my guy opposite
oh my god, but it's it is exhausting and it's like and it is interesting how the media is so
Especially all the late night. It's just like a giant circle jerk where they're all like rubbing cocks and coming on each other
people want cuz Colbert's
Number one and he talks the most
He's really funny. I mean don't get me wrong. I get it. I still walked out
I'm starting to doubt that they have these intro sketches every time and it's like the dumbest thing we should get a
We should get like a compilation of his intro sketches watch her no, I don't know I agree you know who I like
John Oliver
He's okay. He's a little smarmy like he is. Yes. He has his moments
But what is valid what I like about it is it's often educational and he's those are my nothing
He's nothing like a centrist at all, right, but when he attacks
I have friends and family who have been addicted to opiates
Right and when he attacks the the people who created that that loop for those fear
Yeah
I'm just like I couldn't get more of John on. Yeah, is that right?
And it's when he does Trump when he does the other stuff. He does in a way that I think I learn something
So I never mind cuz I love to learn but I never feel like I learned from Stephen Colbert because it's absolutely er
It's clowning, right?
Yeah, but even if I don't agree with John Oliver I learned from John all do you watch 60 minutes? Very rarely in Utah. Yeah
Yeah, 60 minutes is one of the best shows
Watch YouTube, I might actually but they I mean they're like about the opiate
Phenomenon right right much and they really put people on blast and
They absolutely showed right like when you look at what they were doing with most of the really high-end oxycontin
I took oxycontin after my surgery. How is that legal? I was well, I'm morphing directly through my mouth. I couldn't believe
Certainly shouldn't be so what the 60 minutes what report they've talked about like the first of all the drug companies that knew it was
super dangerous and super addictive that had it classified by the FDA as
suitable for use for everyday use
so they fought our with the FDA and they make it suitable for everyday use so they're being sued and fought over like the the
Nicotine, the cigarette companies were you know, like decades ago, but at the same time there's also stuff like pain clinics
Have you heard about this? And that's unbelievable?
You've got these crooked doctors that are setting up pain clinics and like there was one city
Like somewhere in in the rural central united states that imported enough
Oxycontin pills that it was like a thousand per resident of that city of that city, right right like and so
they're like
how is it possible that this isn't raising any red flags either with the drug manufacturer or the FDA or any regulatory because they're basically
Importing tons of drugs through one crooked doctor and and then becoming drug dealers and evil its army to definitely angles
Yeah, right
And so they were saying that at some of these pain clinics
There's just lines out the door like hundreds thousands of people every day just coming here and they're handing out oxycontin
It's crazy. It blew my mind this story. So I think in LA and New York and these kind of big cities
It's it's easy to forget
What this epidemic is, but there are people dying like literally dying
Oh in small towns, like the small towns rather than the small town of my ex-wife now lives in
The small town she lives in is it's called. Well, she's not directly in it, but there's a town near called Escanaba and
They literally called meth kanava because of how bad the drugs problems are there
and the people that have stayed there have either stayed there because they're rich and the only and they're our own business there or
It's people who just couldn't escape right? And so
They're such a small drug force there
They can literally do whatever they want that you can sell whatever you want and no one's there to stop you
No one's there to bust you. And these people are all miserable. So they turn to drugs
Yeah, and the profit is through the roof. I know it's legal or illegal
They don't give a shit the doctors participate there the drug dealers
did you're not gonna bust it if you drive over from New York to this part of Michigan and
Distribute to one of your dealers there and have him live there
You're just gonna make a fortune and no one's ever gonna find out it's crazy. It's really insane
I love sixty minutes though. That's like the last great journalistic show a my opinion. That's not partisan. They're just like beautiful. They don't
How it is and it's really powerful actually just because of what it is I feel like
We are getting to a point where we're starting to have real
Journalists again, and I will use an example here and I Dona hate me using in the example
but there is a journalist at Kotaku called Jason fryer and
Jason has done some really interesting expose days
He did an expose on the game anthem and why it failed and Bioware's overworking culture and how there was only 18
But luckily he went in and they found people that worked for Bioware and talked to them about the experiences there and created an expose
Very similar to what?
Reporters used to do in the 80s, right?
They he blew the lid off of a real story and it wasn't for political gain. It wasn't for social justice reasons
Here's to try to make the gaming industry better. Mm-hmm, and I literally
Applauded him I slid into his DMS the next and I'm like, this is actual journalism. You were doing actual journalism
Please keep doing it. And I don't think he even responded to me because I don't think he likes me but
Yeah, but like it's a following. Yeah, I
Know I think he used to and that's why I can still be mmm
Like exchange words not nice words at some points, too
But I like have so much respect for that guy because he's doing actual
Gaming journalism and actually exists and he's doing it and like I want to celebrate that man. I want to applaud that man
I want to just write him a check and just do this more, please can we have that in this nation?
Not report on your feelings but report on facts and like get actual sources to talk about stuff and not besides it like you said
Tell the story. Yeah, they're out there, but they're not, you know increasingly
less it's
People want juice man. Of course. I want that juice, right?
Let me ask it did you watch the new game of Thrones? I do can we talk about that?
And do you think that we're I mean everyone who's a fan would have washed it by now, right? Uh,
Yeah, pretty much right. I can't see anybody being really yeah
Honestly, and even after watching it I was like you couldn't really spoil this. It's like it just is what it is
Right. I was on YouTube trending dude. I was watching
Everything the trending tab and there was a fucking spoiler on
Motherfucking this was like number three on trending it shows Arya stabbing
Yeah
trending
YouTube I have a fan account mojo
I have a fan account
Um the Sammy 298 it's you know
a fan who pretends to be my dog on Twitter and he spoiled Game of Thrones 30 minutes after was over with a tweet and
Everybody's like boogie you piece of crap. You're spoiling like number one. I'm not spoiling anything. That's a fan number two
Have you checked Twitter because it's literally on the trending page right now
yeah, so
We wanted to talk about that because Dan had some gripes with it pretty happy with that. I enjoy every second. Yeah
Yeah, I did
I actually did I understand the criticism though because like the criticism being first of all
I agree like when the night king was defeated like that
It's like damn he can't he entered the game and immediately left like you have though at that build-up of the whole
Series was this showdown? I mean the the series is called, you know Ice and Fire the
Song of Ice and Fire well that ice that ice it's not really song it's more of an ice of fire
Like a little the story of of icicle it's because they went with a short season right like that cookies
They wrapped that battle could have taken place over two or three episodes
right and you could have the scene where Arya is inside the
The little thing you have these conversations and the Crypt lasts longer. It should have been two or three episodes, right?
Yeah
They just like I had to do it in one episode because they're doing us six episode season or whatever reason
I don't write really long episode when you think about it was it was hour and a half
Yeah, but I think that um, it was mark - I have an HDR TV
I'm like like so I guess that was okay. Yeah, we always turn the lights off and even then on my 70 inch HDR
I'm like why?
There was lots of comments about the dark. Yeah, but I loved that whole beginning widows down are me that was oh that was so
Yeah, it did exactly like he's number one. Here's my biggest complaint about that
Why would those swords go out if they have a spell cast on him? Just because somebody died
It doesn't make any sense. The swords would go out, right? Okay, because I played it up
There's a blizzard they had some babies. Right right, but I remember the Dragons got lost in the blizzard. Oh, that's nice
You might be right. Yeah, but the whole the whole thing was it was really good storytelling right like that moment
I'll never forget that moment. It's the swords begin to fall and the darkness takes over. I'm like it's really poetic
It's really beautiful. And I saw a lot of people complaining about it. I'm like with it was a complaint
Uh, well, it was like that's not realistic. This sword should still be on fire, right?
Oh, and I'm like dude, that's your imagination, right?
I'm like dude stop you were watching snow with zombies and Dragons you are complaining about swords going out bro. It's date
They have a ice spell right? Just whatever we on right whatever reason you want to make up is fine
Well, that wasn't yeah
I didn't I but but I
Understand it's like the night king you have this epic build-up and then all the sudden she's like boom game over, you know
mostly brand and brand that
useless Kim nothing happened that
Was beyond Greyjoy was the character. I most wanted to live
Yeah, cuz I feel like I can relate to the character because like I feel like emotionally were kind of similar characters
That's sad, but that's true right up your penis though
Right examine as much as a 400-pound guy can you know they say for every hundred pounds you lose?
Yeah, you gain back an inch and I'm up to two inches now man. Wait, I'm hoping one day it'll be usable
As I get fatter my dick gets smaller. Oh definitely yeah though, I don't know what
The question is with your penis. I haven't any not an outie. Yeah
helmut fuck myself and i'm like I already
Can you see your penis now? Like how is the visibility great. It's really great. I can do like actual sex. It's weird
Yeah, I can commit sex on somebody if they let have you had indicated. He lost a lot of weight. Mm-hmm
And so what's the difference?
Well at 600 pounds there was one position that worked that was reverse cowgirl
Basically, they you lay down and they yeah, they do the word right word
So it's easy to make sure you're maintaining consent because if they get bored, there's get them leaf
Yeah, right cuz I wouldn't do anything other than like letting it happen. And so now what positions are you?
Um, there's there's a few things we can do like reverse cowgirl still great cowgirl still great, right?
But sure like if you're willing to handle my little skin we can do other stuff you can do like doggy hi doggy
Yes, I think we spoke with that and you put the fat on the girl. Yeah, man, and I skin now it's not bad
It's a skin. I will show you if you guys want to see gross shit. Oh, you're gross. Yeah now we're good
Okay
I just showed it on my youtube channel
Yeah, of course
Here's the next viral moment. Twitter's gonna get mad about this. But so I've gained and lost weight my whole life
So obviously there's still a tremendous amount of fat here, right? You want to talk about Fupa? Do ya? Mmm-hmm
Look at what I'm like at this solution and this is all loose skin and my doctor tells me he wants to do cosmetic surgery
I don't think it's cosmetic at this point. You know, why you hit him by doing do it? Yeah. We're okay
Can I tell I almost want to touch it by the man?
I'm a little sweaty because the airs not working in here right now, but
Yeah, look at it's just loose miserable skin, that's fine
I have it here - I have it leather like the mantis-like play with that. That's fun
like an old man
Never felt that much
That's interesting. So so when you're having sex, it's more like
Lift it up. Put it on your butt
Go to town, right and other girls that are into that there are girls who have put up with it
I've Mountain met a girl who was like, oh I want you wrinkled skin all over my face. Right, right
And so that's the thing like a lot of people think I I really like womanized or whatever
I've gone out with like made a lot of female friends in the last year, right?
But for the most part you it's you got to be a special person before I take you back home and show you this mess
You have trouble like performing when you're heavier, because I had my biggest. Yeah
Yeah, right because I was having hormonal issues
Like I was producing next to no testosterone fat produces estrogen. So I had all these like hormonal confusion confusing blockers
I still was able to get there every time I never had
Completely performing, but that means you're gonna be like, you're gonna be M will be honest
And it's your is your erection quality improves since you've lost weight since I started taking testosterone, but losing weight, right?
How many do you have you ever tried taking like viagra something like that?
No, but I did start taking the antidepressant at the beginning of the year
Yeah, and it's a very common thing where you have trouble finishing. Yes
And so some girls have really liked that and some girls have really been annoyed by that you can tell which ones actually you're enjoying
Wrap it up when they can wrap it up when they're done. Right? Right. Yeah, I
have I started taking that's the really the only side effect I've experienced is that
My dick has lost like a lot of its sensation, you know
which makes it hard to finish and I feel like my dick has shrunk to I
Don't know if it's writing my dick drunk
You would know
yeah, I
Don't know
You've been saying that
Ik yeah
I don't know if it's cuz I'm getting fatter or
Older but like I used to be proud of my dick and now it just looks pathetic, right?
Well, that's part of getting older to you. Right? I don't know. I've gone through the reverse thing because I've lost some weight
What's wrong? I'm like, oh my god. Look at me my two inches. I'm massive now. Yeah
There's nothing there's I mean being proud of your penis is one of the best thing great fantastic as a man
but you could look at your dick and be like
Right on bro, right. So I think that I think I need to be proud of my dick again
Mm-hmm. You should be you should be proud. I
Noticed and are you proud of it? It's not about what you think about my deck ELA. It's about how I feel when I masturbate
Bro, yes, but but yes strange concept, right?
Yeah, oh
I like having women in my life and like having female friends
Right, but you you got to be a special ass girl before I take you back to my place and be like hey
Here's this fucked-up body. Do you want to see it? Yeah, but you got to own it
I mean nobody there's no there's no I like that. Look if I do enough, I'm like this is my body. Do you record?
Yeah, if they say no then they leave. Yeah, but soon you're gonna be dude. You're gonna be a slim tight little twink rock
I work I have so I've really been plateaued at about 340 pounds for a while now
It's been the struggle in between 30 40 and 350 and I know what I need to do
my friend Diamond, Dallas Page
Wants me to come and stay with him for a couple weeks to get in the accountability
Crib and my exercise and eat right and just like film it and and cherrylle my audience and I really want to do it
I think I'm gonna do it after the Khan season where I'm traveling all this summer
But the biggest thing I really want to get the skin rule
Yeah, and my doctor told me when he was looking at this stomach last time he's like that's 30 pounds right there
Yeah, I would literally pound so I'm 340
But maybe I'm a little closer to 320 or 310, right?
Because yeah, and then there's a probably another five ten pounds up here with the the breast tissue
So there's like one surgery here another surgery here. I don't think they'll do both at the same time
maybe they will I don't know what I
Don't want to do it twice, but originally I said I would never do it
I don't want to do it every now it's become such an issue. It's such a terrible
I did you think that you wouldn't want to do the syndrome of yours
Look, I don't care abut it like an actual encumbrance right exactly, right?
You know, I I guess on some level I am human I do would like to be attractive one time. That's not right
It's not but you don't have to be feel ashamed to want to look right but I mean at the end of the day
It's mostly just painful and annoying and and it's causing health concerns now. Yes
Eventually, I will do it. What's your diet? Like well, what's your everyday regimen?
Do you have bad days on diet bad days, right?
like it's a bad day look like a bad day is like
I'm Mexican for dinner and I'll eat like I'll go get fajitas and only like two
Burritos, because that's all I can fit in like two tortillas where the bria and I'll put in the fridge and then for dinner
I'll have two more and
Like that'll finish the meal and some that bad. I know but the weight how's that bad?
That's not bad because I mean it's still best 1500 calories right there 1,500 calories. And so if I had a normal breakfast of like
Responses to bacon into eggs are looking at 600 calories there and then so is that what your normal breakfast looks like bacon and eggs?
I've been doing a lot of turkey bacon and egg whites. Now lately to try to reduce calories a little bit
But that leaves me so hungry that by the time I'm done with working for the day. I'm stressed because I'm
Right. It's so hard. I'm trying to lose weight and it's just I've talked about this before but it's so hard for people
That don't have like a fat gene to understand like what hunger right and you know
You're not hungry
Like I've been eating for breakfast like a bowl of unsweetened
Oatmeal just with water and some berries and that's it. And it's good. I enjoy it
It's really wholesome but you get so fucking hungry, you know towards the middle of the day
That's not your problem though. I mean I get like when I'm hungry I immediately feel it
It's like painful because I'm there's not much a problem, right?
But then I go be small. Yeah. I mean I see with you you'll just get this idea in your head all of a sudden
It just doesn't go away until we get pizza
That's what I like about the surgery though, like greasy foods, like pizza. Most of time just makes me really ill for real
Right. It's kind of nice. So what do you pick out on? What's your like?
You're a far too much fruit at home fruit. Come on
Really too much. But like I do eventually Reese's Cups are like one of my biggest things right?
I had a mate go to Walmart. Why and I'm like
Two weeks having that one two weeks
Everyone up the bigs for the minis
Probably the biggest like how many big can you really go hard? Like two would be really hard now, that's come on
That's not that honey, man. It's you know, but I might have ilysm took a huge hit with a surgery
That's one of the biggest issues right? You mean it's slow
Oh, you mean right slows because my boy, I went through starvation mode for two years, right?
So if what my doctor says is to be believed like I'm taking a bit of a hit to the metabolism
it'll hopefully regulate at some point, right but
But yeah, I'm on a really bad day I eat
3500 calories which is enough to maintain 340 pounds and that's probably like that's a lot right? Yeah, and I'm like a really good day
2500 you know, like that's me
It all comes down to stress and it all comes down to comfort eating like there's this youtuber I won't mention any names
but he made a video about like
I said on twitch one night
I'm like, I don't know that I'll ever get smaller than 350 pounds cuz I'm really happy at my current size
And the reason I said that was not because I'd given up I said that because a lot of people are really worried about me
And I wanted to stop worrying. I wanted them to know that I was happy where I currently am, right
I'm not gonna gain the weight back
I'm gonna try to maintain this and I'm probably keep losing, but I want you to know that I'm happy
That was the important part of that story
But they turned it into who he's encouraging people to stay fat and he's gonna die in the next year and all the stuff
Right and it's super frustrating cuz that's number one. That's not what I said. That's not what I meant. But okay, whatever. Uh
hey, I just wanted people to know that I was happy and I'm so mad remembering this that I feel like I I feel like
I've lost track
Um, have you are you in therapy?
Oh, yeah
I'm in again your problem Oh Tara piss recently actually really because I went in and I'm like
I'm dealing with online hate and I'm like losing subscribers
I've been because subscribe to youtube.com slash look at you tonight, but I've been losing subscribers for a while and it's really frustrating because
YouTube is telling me what used to work doesn't work anymore and I'm really mad about it and
I'm getting a lot of online hate and I don't know how to deal with the online hate and he's like
Would it help if I subscribe to you you?
Know well, I'd be showing you support would you like that kind of support and I'm like you so don't get yeah
I stopped for a while and reconnect these it's like forties fifties, right good finding it. They're a good therapist is super tough
Right and that's if you're ever shopping for a therapist you have to be aggressive and you have to find like I'm sure you're aggressive
about your OBGYN
I'm sure you'd be aggressive about your
Cancer doctor you be aggressive about your general practitioner be even more aggressive about your therapist because if you don't click it's not gonna work
Huge problem is to that you have niche
You haven't kind of a niche issue or your internet right celebrity exactly, which I think in, Arkansas
you probably don't have a lot of people that understand don't I mean and it you don't have to be
Anyone could potentially have insight to understand what that is, but like you have a lot of therapists out here in LA that have
Have experience treating
People with that who are performers that's interest right out his phone therapy exists. I should find one in LA
He wants to be like bone sessions. Yeah, it's possible
I do you think you could find someone who's insightful and talented to dream you there?
But I just think that people are the doctors I worked with don't get me wrong
Like he helped me so much with the divorce if he's listening
I apologize, you know you he helped me so much with my divorce their office is a very good office everybody
There is very talented. He's very good at what he does that said in that one area. He just rubbed me really wrong
Yeah, how do I deal with that, right?
Yeah, that's that was the primary focus of what I needed then I've made it through the divorce
I had made it through the surgery. I made it through and he was very helpful with that
But now this is my primary issue. What do I do? How do I fix it? Well, I could click subscribe on your YouTube channel
That's like some mom shit, yeah
You know what? I mean? Yeah, I'll subscribe to you. He's a cool guy was a clean Oh, what am I?
Yeah, it's tough it's a tough problem, I don't know that there's a solution I think the
Well, I will say and I said on the show last time I'm very fortunate to get to talk to a huge number of graders
Through all the shows and stuff I do and because I'm og
A lot of creators grew up watching me and now that they've made it and gone far past me
they still treat my love and respect and it's when I go to shows I get to talk to everybody and
universally creators are anxious
Universally creators are depressed
Mm-hmm that comes apart with being a creative type right because most creative types are dealing with anxiety depression stuff like that
Yeah
But when it comes to the laser
focus of the internet and the way people treat each other on Twitter because I still believe
I said it on the show last time I got backlash understanding on the show last time. I'll say it again. I
Think the way we treat each other is wrong, I think
We need empathy not hatred. I think we need to give people second chances not destroying one the first mistake
I think that we need to get people an incentive and an ability to learn from their mistakes and become better people and that's
We will ever have good people
You can't do - James Gunn what you did the James Gunn you can't do it
You can't do it and I'm glad they I'm glad they took it away
I'm glad they took a step back and I hope we see start seeing more stuff like that
because when even when you make a real mistake
Even you make a big mistake and say something truly stupid
It is possible to allow that person to continue to exist
learn from their mistakes be a good example and
Become better people and I will always believe that and no matter how much hatred I get for it
Treating each other with vitriol is wrong. It will not solve the problem
well
obviously
That's not I mean, that's not a controversy it is because when you tell bullies at that bullying doesn't work you get bullied
That's what happened. I think the problem. I think I've learned a lot
I think in these past years of having dealt with dealt with things went through a lot. I
think really
It comes down to being able to
Compartmentalize
Like reality from from fiction, right?
And unfortunately, I think that social media is not going anywhere and what it does is just it amplifies, you know
Negativity, of course, it's designed like you want to hear the black pill version of me and what I'm about to say
I genuinely believe this is not hyperbole. I
Genuinely believe that social media is designed to divide us
I generally believe that Jack and and Zuckerberg and all these people that are running these websites know that it's profitable and
Know that it makes them more more rich and more powerful than angry. We all read each other the more we fight. That's why
Not only is it natural human?
Interest that we are interested in the juice that were interested in the drama that we're interested in attacking each other that we love being
Vitriolic that we love being anonymous on the internet attacking each other, but they know that that's not only what we do
But it's profitable to let us do it
Give us an arena to do it to encourage us to do it and you know jack God love you. I
Believe that when Zuckerberg and Jack and all these guys make their changes
They only make changes right up to the point that they can't be sued anymore because that's what they care about. Sure
I believe I believe that there's a possibility that that's true
I think that we are just not well equipped as human beings to deal with that kind of of
Floating consciousness of like social media and what it does to us. I think we're gonna get better at it
I hope because you have to learn basically that what you see and hear there is
Not really real right, right. And if it feels real it's what you see and it's what you hear
But again, the people that watch and support you
I mean you have to be a little bit psychotic to go and leave a hate comment as a Negroni, right?
Yeah, maybe I have no I haven't left a hate comment on anything. I mean since I was I don't know
Ever I don't know
I don't know people people people have said to me like you like everything and I'm like no there's a lot of stuff
I don't like yeah, but I don't talk about the things. I don't like well you can talk about things you don't like
Well, I will for my business for like like, you know
I went to a game company messes up and I want to encourage the game come to get better
I'll talk about that. Right but like if I don't like a creator I can aim for creators off top of my head
I don't like but I very rarely talk about any of them right now. I'm not a huge fan of Jake and Logan
I'm sorry guys, you guys screw up a lot, right? That's what else give me some good. I'm just kidding. I'm not but okay. No
This douchebag who made this video
Encouraging my fans to distance themselves for me because I'm Pat that guy. I'm not going to say his name
But like why do that? Why did that have a lot of views that video, you know?
like as many views as my videos get these days in the hundred thousand where you know, so it's like
It's it's it's hard, but it
really is you have to I think the the pursuit that we all have as as people today and especially
entertainers is like the pursuit of
authenticity
It's like you have to have a frame you have to pursue this idea of authenticity
Within yourself that gives you confidence and ground to stand on right?
It's it's simple, but it's like the hardest thing to do in your life for me. It's almost like a a
Lifelong pursuit because what does it mean to to be authentically yourself?
how do you do it and
At the soul the center of what it means is being having a confidence to know and believe in the things that you're doing
We're the right things it represent who you are right when I was first coming up being authentic wasn't
Wasn't a problem
I didn't even have a choice everything I did was authentic
but then when you start hearing voices and dissent and thoughts and tell, you know
This is how this is you authentically or this is you authentically or you've changed. So that's your not authentically you anymore
They like this content, but they don't like this
You know, it all goes into your right consciousness if you think about it or not
And you're really you're struggling with the housing voice is ten thousand words a million voices all saying different things
It's like a version of schizophrenia it right, right
And eventually you just have to separate yourself from and you seem to have done that entirely for the most not entirely, right?
But for the one thing I've been working a lot
Towards you have to be your authentic self and if you listen to that stuff you can't anymore
after the last two years
Yes, I would read what they were saying on these forms and these subreddits and some I'll read and be like, oh my god
I need to change things. I'm
Different the lives like those people never gonna like me no matter what I write
You don't have any way they literally they don't I owe you is saying they don't know you
Exactly. They don't fucking know anything about who you really are. I
saw it I saw a
Tweet the other day had your name in it and I was up there next year
And it was a list of people that PewDiePie followed who were Nazis. Oh, yeah. I thought it was me you
Yeah, how plain Adar you and Nazi? Here's something else. Somebody said I was in our article
It was it was actually got a lot of coverage. It's insane Alpha Omega sin were a guy out of, Texas
He's he's very lbgtq plus a sort of friendly as I know, right?
Apparently I have transphobic which I literally I own a gaming store now. I just put fifteen grand into a new gaming store
And yes, that is a profitable thing. Right? So I'm not an angel
I'm not a saint I plan to make my money back because it's a store, but we owned one store called ye
Er need to make that caveat, of course because that's people try to take away what I'm about to say
Right, and I don't want to let him I don't want to let him. All right. No
because after after upsetting the lbgtq bin the last time I was here I wanted to make up for it and I don't talk about
This very often I'm talking about it now a year later, you know
but I don't talk about this stuff very often the way I made up for it is a
Transplant of mine Olivia Tosa at oats olive on on Twitter if you want to go for give her a follow
She opened up a store called gear
and
When she opened up
I bought a bunch of cards from her personal collection to help open the store
And the reason I wanted to do
Because she was going to register it as an OB GT coupe plus a stone
And if you hear the word say Sona you roll your eyes, let's say so a SafeZone specific safestone, right?
And if you hear the term SafeZone and you roll your eyes because who wouldn't need that. We are in, Arkansas
That first store was two hours away from Harrison
Arkansas where the current Grand Wizard of the Ku Klux Klan lives we opened our
lbgtq plus safe zone in
Clan territory people. Okay, and and we did this what the safe zone means is of course. It's a safe zone for everybody, right?
No matter who you are come play at our store. You're gonna have a good time at our store
You won't have to deal with politics or hate or anything or a gaming store
But if you're an lbgtq plus member we have someone on site who can counsel you and help you deal with life issues
You're feeling suicidal
if you're having trans issues if you're having problems getting bullied in Arkansas if the claim is breathing down your back come to us we
Will help that's what our that's one of the things our store offers
So the owner of the store my friend Glenn says to me I want to open another one an hour and a half away
Will you give me some money? I cut him a check right there. I didn't think about it
Will you register this one as a no TVT kills? So so yes. Well, Illinois the Klan. Yes. Here's my money
Well, I'll pay you back. I hope you do because I would like to have the money back but as it is right now
I'm a partner in the store
Let's kick some ass and if I get the chance
I'll open one an hour away from Arkansas AR from Harrison and then now half an hour from Harrison
I'll build one in Harrison and let it burn them. Let them burn it down
but the internet thinks I'm anti lbgtq on what plan that's the so that's the thing is like
Most I'm sure that first of all, you know yourself you are the people that know
You know that you aren't people your fans your actual fans, which is the vast majority of people who consume your content
I would assume right know that you aren't
So again, you're you're facing an unreality
You are responding to it's a madness really happening. It is maddening. It's totally medic and I don't think we're equipped to deal
That's what I'm saying like to deal with that insanity, but we have to first acknowledge that it is insanity
right and that that's what I mean the the pursuit of authenticity right because you have
The whole concept of on tête authenticity get so mixed up
What other people expect from you or the fact that we change over time as online?
Personalities that we are we have to be allowed to evolve. We can't stay in a stasis. That's not authentic is right
So you have to know who you are. You have to know what you're about and and it is such a difficult thing
but when you know
When you really know who you are authentically and you can be yourself fluidly then then I think that's what can help nullify
These voices that but for me, I just I I tried to not engage with them as little as possible
I'm trying really hard not to it's very difficult because I have an anxiety disorder
and I get very anxious and I will dissociate and when I'm dissociate I need to not have my phone near me because I will
Talk to somebody for 20 minutes and not even control of what I'm saying. Well
so it's a problem with not just us but everyone like for example Twitter reporting some stupid Oh
The internet was upset about this
news
Nobody was maybe and fuse. That's what Jack does
He makes his money. That's how that's how that platform gets investors
But then it's not just then it becomes a story on articles and you know it
Yeah, and I think you're right about that. They are stirring up drama for profit
The one that really reminds me of that Shane Dawson story that was on Twitter news that he's like a pedophile
Twitter runs this story in the headline
It's a non-story that they created from like one random bullshit and it gets blown up into this huge story
That's that is actually a bigger problem because I mean that's like fake news
You know, right you're creating a that's why I mean that's just you know that
Slander, that's just libel
Level we need to know how to separate this stuff, but then for reporters for example
They also need to know not to take it at the same
Give it I came again
One of my biggest focus is the gaming world and like as much crap as I gave Mortal Kombat 11
there are people actually reporting that it takes six thousand dollars to unlock everything in Mortal Kombat or you can play the game idiot like
literally
Edie Boone had to come out and say no most of the skins that that you can by our our
Purchase play role through the game and most of the skins that are playable through the game
You can't buy like what are you talking about?
You people are lunatics
Right, but it doesn't matter because all these gaming channels see that one headline that was falsely reported and then they run with it
It's absurd it's a certain, you know, I I've done that a couple of times
I've taken Kotaku at their word polygon at their word and
and thought oh
Look at the sources didn't verify myself reported it and then had to take the video down because I fought like an asshole
Well, that's fun. I mean we all fall prey to it
it's it's everywhere but I think even not just like entertainers but everybody I think is
Gonna be faced with we have kind of an existential
Crisis of identity that we all need to face with because on Instagram you don't see reality on on social media
You're not seeing reality and I think we all need to find our authentic selves. I think that's like a huge a
huge thing that
We all need to do it's why I love Jim Carrey
Because I don't know if you've seen this but Jim Carrey's a bit of a space cadet these days, right?
yeah, but he's living as a
Himself as he can be I totally agree and that's why I like his whole Twitter thing is very political
I love his cartoons though. They're freaking genius. They're so funny. But he's he's being very authentic. Mm-hmm
Yeah, and so and so again people can say whatever they want. They can call him a hack that can call him part. Whatever
I'm sure they say terrible things about him, but that you know, he's Teflon, right?
He's authentic. And so that's kind of what I've been trying to deal with. I do think that disc like I almost never
It's a shame because you want to engage with the good people that care about you and write and well
But ultimately you kind of got to not take that too
Because like what can have it's not a critic also right in a sense, but it's like, you know
They don't know who you are
They don't know you I've had people say you saved my life and I'm like no either the work. Yeah
I I provided the temporary distraction, right?
Or you know you because I was 500 pounds and you started losing weight. I started losing weight
I've lost even more than you you helped me with that. No, I didn't I made a video
You know, I'm glad that it registered in the world in some way
But you're giving me far too much credit
Because you had to do the dieting you had to do the work you're stronger than me. You're better me
You were more successful than me. Well what planet am I responsible for your success?
Right, but they want to give you that I'll take it. Well, so see you see what you're saying
it's not I have trouble accepting compliments like that till I actually I
Talked about it with my therapist and he made an interesting observation. It's like you have no problem
Not accepting the good but you absorb all the bad. Mm-hmm and you got to not take either of it
Mm-hmm, right cuz it's all kind of
nuts I'm gonna say superficial not that their feelings are but that they don't know you they don't know you and it's great that you're
What you're creating?
Control reaction when we're the other right that means that you're successfully
Igniting people's emotions through through your heart form or your my own. Right right. But again, they don't know who you are
Right, and and you can't from a 10 minute YouTube video or 10,000 YouTube videos. You can't from a 4-hour Twitter stream
You can't yeah, you can't and I'm trying to be the most authentic self that I can be, right
But how do I not in a world of life scream fails and and Twitter clips and all this other stuff?
How can you be truly authentic about life, right?
yeah, I what I would say to you and what do I do for myself is just to
avoid it
the best thing for me because think about like this let's say that there's a clip of me on
Livestream fails from one of our livestream that's 10,000 points and everybody's clowning on me because I did something super
Embarrassing right if I don't see that post I am
Unaffected you're right. I am the same
The next day the next week that shit didn't affect me at all. I have people so dedicated to ruining my day
That they every time I tweet they immediately like posts this the the mall the miserable stuff that's being said about me. I
Have two different people from several email accounts because I blocking them so they change email accounts all the time
They send me email digests of the hate. I've gotten them read it. Hey, you should see this. Look at this terrible shit
There's a we found this out about you we found this out about you. I'll click on it
It's all lies and slanders all May anyways something I said taking completely out of context, right?
Yeah, you're not like you're a Hitler. You're sex out of shit
whatever, right and and but it's the same people spoiled in-game for me, I think because I got an email from
so-and-so kills so-and-so at gmail.com Oh Mike
notifications on my phone you got an email from
Batman kills the Joker right? You know, I don't like wow. I know I'd already got it ruined on Twitter
But at least you tried you're right
but like I there's people out there so
Dedicated to me and that I stopped playing the victim like then these people need to stop victimizing me
Well, you got to stop giving them attention like you're talking about them. Now it just emboldened
It's pretty incredible that there's people out there that care about you that much. What's hilarious
It really is what I read it for you you need to I mean you you pulled in them and you empower them
Right, and I really need not to when like somebody like somebody pointed out. I just need to delete twitter
Twitter needs to be a no because that again is giving them too much and that's why arena so long I said in a video
You install Twitter on my phone and then 20 minutes later. I got an email round up somebody saying, haha
We win ha ha ha ha and I'm like, I'm reinstalling Twitter. All right, now that will travel. Anyway, here's what you should try
For a month don't read use Twitter. Don't read the mentions straight. I'll look at like verified
Notifications only because those are relatively safe from those though, so then don't look at it
I I could also live without it just use Twitter
Don't read the mentions use Instagram. Don't read the mentions
Don't go don't go to subreddits where people are talking about you we are not built to it. You look a comment
Alright, I'm learning clearer. Right since I got my teeth fixed. I've been way better at it
It's just really hard with an anxiety sword. It's really rude for anybody
It's really you are not it's like eavesdropping on people talking about you when they don't know that you're there
But no they at me though. They email to me
They want to know my username on on on on reddit all the time bro if I want anyway
Especially for someone who is uh, you know, I used to cut
I used to self-harm. I learned some techniques like wearing a rubber band
Maybe I think on at least one of the podcasts. I was wearing a rubber band for stress relief to harm myself
Squeezing ice it was another technique
I learned to host squeeze another way to harm yourself without leaving scars that
Got me out of cutting, but obviously another form of self-harm is eating herself to that. Mm-hmm
And that's what I'm I've been in one of my biggest ones so reading this stuff is another form of self-harm
I know it's gonna ruin my day. I know it's gonna ruin my mind. I know it's gonna hurt tremendously
So let's do it because that's what I want to do. I want to be miserable because I hate myself, right?
I know so hard. I know what you mean to it
but I feel like I like dieting is just as important for for you right now as to
Give yourself the exercise of let's say for a day because it seems like you you you have trouble
Resisting for too long. I'd say for a day or three days or a week or whatever. You can't don't read anything
Yep, you know used YouTube we used Twitter do everything don't
Go in the comments just close it me, for example, it was so hard if we post a video to
just post it and then not look at I
Couldn't do it
I could like I would say I was gonna do it and I would still look at
But now I I really do it now. Oh, no. No, I'm gonna be like obsessively
Scrubbing Twitter. They you know find the one guy that hated me and I because I'm a piece of shit
I will ignore all the people that said oh my god, you're so grand the podcast they love you so much
You look so different. You're wonderful. I love the new tail for you to not read the comments. Can you try it?
I'm gonna try. Alright, so we try from this podcast specifically if I did a podcast I wouldn't read the fucking comments
I'll say right damn now, even if I thought it went great actually
especially when I thought it went great because I'll go there and then I'll be like
Oh, it was awful. And now I feel awful about it right cording to the comments you mean, right?
You're right my mind and my attentive self and and in my present mine
I I thought it what I worry about is I'm gonna be like and I was there
What what how do I hurt somebody on this podcast?
Who did I harm? What community or harm? Well, how do I fix it? That's my problem
my problem is I'm someone out there's going to claim something I said in this podcast is
Genuinely hurt their community and I'm going to make up for that their problem
Right the thing that if you're really something that would hurt someone you would know it
Exactly. I'm here right now. I don't think I said anything bad and
When this is over, I'm gonna be like, oh we're done and I'm not gonna look at your smart and you're smarter than me
I mean it took me so long to actually do that. I know what you mean
It's so hard but sometimes I'll say something stupid and I'll really regret it in my own authentic self
I will say that it was really outrageous
You did say the n-word several times earlier in the show, and I thought that was a little
Surprised by that, but if you thought that was fine then yeah
Here's what I will say. Here's what I want. Here's it. Here's what I want to trend. Let's let's see this friends
Let's see if they can clip this out. Okay unison on board as loud as you can I'm gonna get way worse than that
Okay, let's do it
I'm gonna say to love thy neighbor Oh get and I don't listen to me. I want you to love yo
That soundboard doesn't do that. I
want to say that the way the left and the right treat each other the
Way to the left and right treat each other is not going to work and it's just going to further divide
Yeah
And we don't choose empathy and we don't choose love and we don't learn to chav
love our white neighbor and our black neighbor our straight neighbor and our gay neighbor our conservative neighbor and our
Democrat neighbor and our centrist neighbors god forbid
We actually give those guys credit because they make up the majority of the country, right?
God forbid that we start treating immigrants and and and and natives and and and citizens all the same and we remember that we are
All Americans and some of us are trying desperately to become Americans and we start treating each
Other with love and respect and kindness we might just end this apocalyptic cycle. We're currently in the middle of and
Maybe things a bit better because what we're doing right now sure ain't working
yeah, I you know, I I Teeter on that myself because I go I
Listen to the news and I listen to the late nights and I consume all the media and I go man, it feels so
Messed up right now and I go it wasn't this bad when I was a kid
And I go well, I didn't really care about anything when I was a kid, but I think about Bill Clinton impeachments
Think about how much people hated Obama?
If you go back if you go back back back back and look at like all the way back to like Thomas Jefferson
Verse, you know Alex under Hamilton or whatever
That shit was just as crazy then of course it is now, of course
So I
Think maybe I started to think maybe he's not that bad. Maybe things are fine
You know like we just got old I think social media amplifies everything it makes it feel way worse than it is
but overall the country is
Safer than it's ever been. I mean we have trouble we have drug problems and we have there's issues
Obviously as there always will be but I mean people are doing good
overall
Poverty and around the whole world is down. Here's what is new. Here's what is new
Six weeks ago fact check this if you want because the articles are there. Mm-hmm we had
Counter-protesters white supremacist counter protesters on the Capitol Steps in Little Rock, Arkansas. Mm-hmm chanting
seven million more
That that happened. Yeah happened that's reality. And I know the claims always existed
I know why swainton said then we'll anymore. Are they talking about the Holocaust?
Oh, they're giving us more credit than we because we usually we say six and they say it's greatly exaggerated, right?
Well, then now they have been moving more. That's right, you know, they believe in the Holocaust at least I guess. Yeah and III
Where's coming from? Why is this half a day at all fixed? Well, they don't race em, it's there
I mean even during World War Two there was fuckin Nazi sympathizers here in America. That's true
I'm just you know
not anti-semitism is as as classic as it gets this is why I say this is why I struggle with my
Nihilistic thoughts and like the PTSD you like suicidal thoughts are a very common thing with PTSD, right?
and and so I struggled that all the time and I
This the last two years of my life have been
Simultaneously the best two years my life in the worst two years of my life
There have been periods of time where I was sitting in my closet with a shotgun ready to Kurt Cobain myself
Corner shot, you know not that bad. But I like this is the adoration but no no firearm
No, I went to purchase one, but I knew it would not be safe to have it in my home
My roommate does have one and it's in a safe that I don't have the code for and I don't want to have the code
For it because I know when I dissociate I could make a very irreparable mistake and I do not want to do that
So I do not feel safe or the gun, but that's it. I've
struggle with suicidal ology in the last couple of years
Don't worry. I'm not going anywhere as long as my dog's alive. I'm alive
It's as simple as that or I'm not leaving that dog leaving him for five days
Like right now, I'm getting pictures from my roommate of him. Just laying on my bed waiting for me to come home
I'm not leaving that dog. Okay, but that said
I've also had moments where I'm on a
tower in Brooklyn eating lunch with
my favorite creators and and then going to place in my favorite video game six months before anybody else gets to play them and and
Meet some of my rockstar developers and so it's been I don't know
It's been a really interesting couple of years
But when you when you look at III don't think I belong in the human race and not that I'm better
I think I'm far worse because I feel like I empathize far too much. I
Empathize with the wrong people I empathize with my haters more than I do my people who love me I swear I do. I
Tried more Vince them. My therapist told me you can't reason with unreasonable people, but I want to so desperately
I want to save them from their hate, but you know what? My therapist told me about stuff like that
He says you have to understand that these people are there to hurt you
You're not wrong. They are there. You have to understand. These are people that are
expressly expressly going out of their way to hurt you and I can't comprehend that I I
Here's a true story people tell me I make this up I make this up and I don't care because I know it's true
20-some year old me and when I got my second apartment ever I'm sitting in this runni beatdown part of Fayetteville, Arkansas
and I'm playing video games and like 1 o'clock in the morning Friday night and
The front door opens and a hand reaches in and starts fumbling for the LightSwitch
And I'm like what the higher I get up and I grab the only weapon we have in the house
which is a baseball bat and
Right as he finds a light switch I swing the door open and I'm like, can I help you?
And he's like, oh man, I'm sorry. I'm drunk and I'm like, yeah clearly because can I I'm just trying to use the phone
I'm like no you're trying to break into my apartment. Why you should I cut off light he's because those windows they're open man
I want them by seeing me in the office. I'm like this isn't an office. This is my apartment, dude
You're clearly trying to rob me. No. No, I just want to make a phone call
Who you trying to call my wife I'm drunk I can't drive I don't want to drive home
It's 1990 a tiger grabbed my corded phone I bring it to him
I set him down on my couch to tell him not to move. I handle my phone
He calls his wife and she screamed at him. I can't believe you drunk
Were you out screwing that whore that I'm not coming to get you you walk on?
He hangs up the phone defeated and starts to walk out of my apartment and I'm like, dude
Are you really drunk you guys? I think I'm safe enough to drive home
And I don't think you are where you live
Well, I live in springdale. Well, that's only 15 minutes man. I'll Drive you
So a guy who might it might have been trying to break into my home
I ended up giving him a ride home
Because that's the kind of person I am I if I died in that process he shot me and carjacked me
I'm glad to die that way because I was trying to help somebody right and I think that probably makes me an idiot
I've probably not as reserved as the rest of the human race the human race loves vitriol
The human race is aggressive. The human race is an asshole. I'm a cock like whatever that word means for you
I'm probably that I am I'm a beta male
I'm a empath and and I'm too empathic and I do it far too much the worst thing I learned through therapy about myself
My best friend has listened to me complain for 25 years. He's seen me
Dissociated he's seen me angry. He's seen me hurt. He's seen me sad and
I told my therapist one day that's why I love my best friend because he's seen me at my worst and
Guess what Steve? How often does he see yours? I said all the time. He sees all the anxiety from the work
he sees all the anxiety from life and the struggles and
He's helped me take a shower and I broke my shoulder for god sakes
He's been amazing and it goes but how do you treat strangers?
And I'm like, well, I try to earn a stranger's trust. I give him a good experience. I give him a good time
I'm kindness Rangers, right? I'm very kind to strangers. It's like you gotta flip the script
the person you should be giving the good experience to
is your best friend is the people in your life the people who support you the people you should not give a crap about the
People you complain to the compete pool. You're mean to are the people you don't know
Sure, you know yeah, but that's that's always been my biggest issue. I think that's normal though
I think part of the
Slip up is that when we start to think that in all all things are normal and then that can really drive you crazy
I mean
I found that in my life and I think it's normal that the people closest to us are the ones we can be the shittiest
too because you become I think either complacent or you become comfortable around them and
they can often become a
Punching bag and it's not that it wasn't verbally abusive good
she's like sad and depressed and hurt when I should be on for that person right when I go to VidCon and I meet a
Fan I am on and I'm happy and doesn't matter how much pain I'm in or how sad I am a that's not it
Yeah, but I mean at the same time you can't be on at home, right?
But I want to I want to for the people who love me
I want to look I want to treat him the way they deserve to be loved. Does that make sense? Yeah
No, I know exactly what you mean totally
I mean that's part of why I went on antidepressants
Because I was so irritable and I was such a little bitch all the time such a whiny
Cocksucker many to myself because I was like just such a punk all the time and so irritable
I'm like
I knew that I was just for the most part
Making ela miserable for being around me and I wasn't always like that, you know, of course
Yeah, and so it's actually been a complete 180 for me in terms of
dealing with that and now you have a baby coming along and so your responsibility and
maintain that child's childhood is so
important and it's coming from someone who was abused growing up and watch their parents fight growing up and like, you know,
I was not sheltered from that at all. I was thrown right in the middle of it, right?
You know
My mother claiming my father was a homosexual because he had blood in his underwear and like all kinds of crazy shit and eight euro
I don't know what any of these words mean
I'm eight, but I know they hate each other and I know that apparently that's bad and cheating on each other
And I know she has a boyfriend and like holy
You know maintain you you've got to be the best Ethan you've ever been, you know
And I look forward to seeing how that works out
Yeah, we're running out of time man we got about a month left here
But I can't - it's very they're doing somersaults how uncomfortable are you right now?
Like as it has been I guess it's pretty uncomfortable
Like when I need to get out of the it's like a whole I'm making noises like an old person now, you know
it's like to be a fat guy that she's paid to do like
Exactly. I'm and I gotta tell you being skinny is so much more comfortable
Oh, yeah, cuz you're a tiny person like that's all are you?
Fuck that. Oh, you're five. For some reason. I think you're short. But yeah, you're so skinny. I can't imagine carrying that extra weight
What it's got to be like four it's got to be a whole other experience
Mm-hmm, and I can't even say it like I'm you like I'm used to I don't know it like that
Oh, yeah, well people I can't even be myself people complain about manspreading still right and like when you're a morbidly obese with all this
Fred I literally can't close my legs. Yeah. Yeah
somebody got annoyed at the the borderlands 3 event and we were like on
Bus together and I was like sitting halfway in the aisle, right? But I my leg accidentally touched his leg and he's like
And I'm like dude, come on
I mean, I'm not sweaty. I just took a shower. I don't smell bad. I'm not your typical fat guy right now
I did everything I couldn't possibly do but I do
Still take up space like I'm a human being and he wasn't a small guy either
He was like six four and so he was taking about more than his share
How did you know he was irritated because I just got bumped his leg
And so he gave you that got hurt right? You grant them back. No, I apologize. Yeah, you should have fucking I'm a cook
No, I don't. I don't like that word. I like the word and I like that word and I don't like beta mail. I
Don't like I don't believe in any of it, that's what people call me but I don't believe that about myself right? I I genuinely
Believe is that everybody's a little bit different and in the way that we're all different
We are the same and this is just no I choose to live my life and I'm a product of the things and experiences
I've had and I
just choose to do whatever my brain tells me to do and your brain might tell you to punch that guy in the face for
Grunting and my brain says, hey, let's make his day nice and comfortable
Let's apologize and let's you know make yourself to defecating joke because it's just the way I feel better about it
Mm-hmm, and people do whatever they do. I want you to do me a favor. Yeah
Try not to read the comments. I'm not going to I didn't feel happy about this we have
Experienced a off Twitter to see what what one thing. I said got taken completely out of context and used to bully me
No, I'm going to completely avoid ready to figure out what one thing
I said out of context that was used to bully me and
I'm going to try to not watch the YouTube videos about what thing I said out of context that will be used to bully me
Because don't get me wrong
I'm all for calling somebody on their crap when they make a big mistake, right and maybe I've made mistakes right obviously
Right and you should call people out on the mistakes. You don't have to be an asshole about it
That's what I think but they will and they they're they will it's inevitable right? It's absolutely inevitable. I don't know
Just try it yet. Try it. Try not to read. I'm going to yeah, I'm going to how do you feel that it's gone
It's gotten better through therapy in the last six or seven months
I've really learned how to avoid it. I just do not read read it anymore
Created I created a finally second reddit account just to read like my magic
Exactly, right? Yeah, so I don't even have to see people tagging the main we can even block
Subreddits from showing up on your feet. Whoo. That's interesting. Yeah. I haven't read it
And I finally hired some mods and said you guys just deal with it
I don't care anymore. If you want to leave hate up there leave hate up there
If you want only positivity positivity they do it the way they want to do it. I don't I don't participate or care
Twitter I have some filters in place now tor I just don't have to see certain key words and stuff II I
Hired a guy to write a bot that blocked everybody that used like one particular phrase
which I don't want to say right now because I want to emboldened anybody that was just so tired of hearing that phrases like I'm
Done with this. I don't ever want to see it mentions again. Mm-hmm. I ended up like blocking
I think I think if bought ended up blocking several hundred people
Oh you you?
People who use that word who tweeted at you. You didn't lock them. Yeah
And I was like, I just I don't want to hear anymore. I want to hear I don't see it
Somebody Creator telling me they knew somebody who could do that for me
I don't know if they logged into my account personally did it? I don't know if they set up a bond
I think they set up a bot they did
How are they did it and I'm like II you if you use that phrase you are an irresponsible
Twitter user and I don't care what you have to say and you don't deserve access to my tweets
You do not deserve to see what I have to say. Are they?
And that's how I feel. Well, it sounds it sounds like
It's great to see a you've come a long way
I mean look at you you you have
Transformed the confidence is coming with the change with all all great and worthy changes come with pain exactly. They all come with pain
I already
Yeah, absolutely look a lot worse on camera because like my cameras especially I haven't set the very whitening and look
It's just shocking right? You know, it's it's just shocking its system with weight loss is just shocking
It's just such a different. I got a full makeover as well my friend Jared
He's like look your bone structure is gonna be a little different after you the teeth. Mm-hm
So do you trust me to like shave you and give you a haircut the whole nine yards in link list? Let's go
so he took me to a salon and
told her what to do and came out looking very different on top of that and they're like I chose these frames even though I've
Never really liked the thick plastic frames. I had some bruising from the surgery under my eyes
And so I was like, I'll just cover them up with the frames and people like oh, you look great
I mean, alright if that's what you like. I like it too. So we'll do it. Yes, man
I just haven't still be alive at this point because I like to told you the last time I was here
When we walked into that surgeons for the consultation, he's like we need to rush you into surgery you are dying
Now you will be dead in a year
So we're in process normally takes almost a year
I want to rush you through and get you done within four to five months because if I don't you will die
Yeah, so I'm just glad to be alive. Well, you look so much better
Even from the last time we saw you said you've lost 40 pounds. It's it's like you look
Incredible. Thank you, ma'am. You look incredible
Keep going man. Looking forward to the next time we can get you out here. Now. You have to do another update. Absolutely
Let's do me early. Yeah
I'll come back in here next year and I'll get in my old clothes and help Oh
Turns out a gurney boots are now
Gonna we're gonna keep you honest. I'm doing my damnedest ma'am. Yeah promise you I will promise you that I am going to either
Lose the rest of weight or die trying there you go. I don't know why you need to die trying
Oh because I mean we all die it's inevitable, right? Yeah
I just want to make sure I die doing my absolute best right from my death. Yeah. Yeah, I hear ya
Well fantastic, what do anything we didn't cover that we want to cover
We got your sex life. We got the touching the Fupa. We got what?
We don't enjoy a more Game of Thrones or endgame. I loved him
I in-game was such a ride for me because the very first Iron Man movie and no spoilers, obviously
But the very first Iron Man movie when they invented the Marvel formula for that movie I couldn't have been happier
I walked to them I hated Iron Man I thought is a dumb character
Mhm, and they did what they did with it and they like cast Robert Downey jr
And he was the best guy ever and I'm like, holy shit
And then this 11 year ride has been the best experience of my life because I got to see Return of the Jedi
In the theater, but I need to see the original Star Wars or Empire in the theater because I was too young
but I got to experience this one and I hope the the younger people out there who got to experience this understand new experience your
Star Wars, this was your Star Wars. And which Star Wars could be your Star Wars, but it can't because it's Matt Terrell now
But uh, it's really bad. I have no interest in seeing the return of the Empire Emperor or whatever the fucking next one. Alright, right
Garden of scarred the rice of Skywalker. Yeah watch I don't really understand that
How what does that I don't see it's not that I don't understand. It's not I just don't care now
The last one was it will regardless I get that I get what you're saying about the Marvel Universe
I like Game of Thrones more personally, but I I liked
Endgame, I thought it was great. I like the fur. I thought the first one was better. Oh
Yeah, I well it has to be better right because you think about that and infinity war and top right infinity war is the Empire
Strikes Back right because the Empire Strikes Back got to completely do something the other two original
Trilogy could in the trailer to do they literally got to do whatever the fuck they wanted they get into
However, they wanted to because they have a follow-up movie. You knew that within where they're making Empire
We're gonna get them to make Return of the Jedi. So this is depressing and crazy and weird and nuts
we can do it, right and so
Infinity war has the option of completely
disregarding the hero's journey
completely disregarding modern modern storytelling and just do whatever wanted to so by
Just the merits of filmmaking. It will always be the better phone and he has to be yeah, right
I enjoyed both equally but one it's clearly the better film. Mmm
Mmm easy, but but yeah, whatever. I got YouTube by the way. Oh, yeah
What were your gripes with YouTube you want to talk about that? Yeah, I'm so mad. You know what's going on?
so number one a lot of people wanted to know can I still do the Frances voice with my TV right and number one you've
Heard that I have a more natural Lisp right now, but I do plan to get rid of that Zbornak obscure the sideway Lisp
It's still pretty good
In fact, I think I sound more like the original voice that I never did
expecially when I go low because the one I'm pissed off about his head bone that
motherfucking Mortal Kombat
My spend oh, you know
You got good?
but this is just
dead on YouTube they D monetized my entire back catalogue and it was a huge financial hit because they're swearing because there's
prepared
Violence they start if you curse within the first 30 seconds, they do you monetize like that. I was like what?
Yes, I say shit at 28 minutes or 28 seconds. Yeah, and they demonetized
Yeah, I video. Okay when they stick with it, right you literally I can't swear on YouTube. That's how pure Dan it's become
Yeah, I'm like dude. I was talking to my guy. I'm like, man
I feel like this has become worse than working with like a television executive at this point
So, oh he said to me go work with the TV executive and then let me know how it is
But it will be like that one day I genuinely believe it will be well it's already again, yeah and so my friend mcjuggernuggets
Who did the psycho series started an app called story fire? And I wanted to plug it here
story feiyr.com sto
ry pi re there's also an app on Android and
he's like starting creating what he's always done is narrative content and he wants me and
kid behind a camera and other people have just been thrown off of youtube to
Come create narrative content again because my YouTube rep is like look, could you do Francis without the swearing?
Can you do Francis without getting angry? Have you watched a Francis video? That's the entire character?
Right and I've experimented with the formula. One of the biggest experiments have been doing is blending
Boogie as a character with Francis as a character and making him the same
And I did that for a couple of videos. Did it like a
stupid little
Podcast and then like harass people in an airport has the hybrid character and there was a hybrid character
I was working with mcjuggernuggets and it's funny because it pulls the algorithm. It doesn't realize that I'm swearing
It doesn't realize that I'm angry because they think I'm being boogie for the first third of the video right and then I go into
the ADC towards the end and
The bot isn't checking the last part of the video or some reason. I think it's just the first 30 second break Lane
No, literally, that's what my youtube rep said the first third always keep the first third a clean
Alright the rule I've heard specifically is 30 SEC a good. Well, definitely the 30 seconds, but I mean, I agree
I mean if he tells you a third right then I would just time it out and then be like
But here's the thing even with a million more
There's something that the sponsors are seeing where they get to choose the quality of the video as determined by YouTube now
I guess I don't know
I've never been told that but my
Cp/m or like the money I earn from YouTube if I talk if I make a gaming video
I'm just going to throw some numbers out of these numbers in that group
If I made a YouTube video and Francis got a hundred thousand views, I might make a hundred dollars
Yeah, I am alone. Sometimes 60 sometimes forty brought that video, right?
Yeah, which is difficult when you're breaking a 400 hour television when you're destroying it. There are excellent. I
made a video and this is an actual number I made a video about
Sakura
versus Kirby are not not Kirby Yoshi and
How one game is is being dissed for being too easy in one game is being dissed by for being too hard, right?
and it only got sixty six thousand views and I made
300 bucks off that's sixty six thousand views right right. Now you tell me which is the better choice as a creator
Yeah at that point right, but I want to pay my bills. I can't do Francis videos anymore
That's why I'm gonna start doing almost story fire where I can go back to burning down houses and wrecking cars and destroying Xboxes Detroit
Televisions because it gives me the option to keep my creative integrity. You can't keep your crazy
You're talking about being your authentic self anymore. You literally can't be that on YouTube anymore. It doesn't matter who you are
There's a literally matter who you are. You have to edit yourself and censor yourself and make yourself
Look at your abs a little best not just because of how bitch we're all at
The internet is not just because if you make one small mistake, you're over, right?
But because YouTube themselves will no longer pay you for being your authentic self. They want you to be
Will Smith
Or nothing else. I totally agree
I think they're really have a problem on their hands and I've been talking a lot with them trying to get them. I
The CEO came and visited us a couple weeks ago and I spend most of time telling her
Why are you guys unable to monetize this kind of continent you have this Google preferred program and you have all these
family-friendly channels in it making tons of money
Why is it that my content and people who make content like mine for?
Teens for you know mature amateur or mature audience that you'll find on cable television that you'll find out radio with advertisers
Lined up out the doors to target that valuable market of more mature audience
Why the why the hell can't you guys figure out how to monetize this content because I said what?
What's the what age she goes well
She goes well, we've had trouble pitching they're trying to put together like a Google preferred for edgier channels. Hmm
Well, we were having trouble pitching it
I'm like, you're not pitching it right because when we were with complex, they used to sell direct ads on ours
And it was sold out non-stop. Of course. It was it was ridiculous. They had
Junk food. They had like a, you know Doritos soda beer alcohol
Movies it was like every freakin view was monetized and I'm like, dude
there's no they gotta figure it out because it's it's and why you don't just pitch it like
The Mortal Kombat, you know order MTV right? Here's the add your YouTube
Well, they need to run so it's no they need one code
They need to pitch it like because they're all afraid that's gonna be like Kitty's shed and terrorism
But it's curated group and you need to picture like these are more engaged
Interested audience and a specific demographic that are willing to spend money and different products, right?
Is there 1835 males and most the case and they're interested in these products and you're going to get a better targeted?
advertising advertising to these people
How would they not figure that out? So I'm pushing them hard good. She did say that they just had such a rough
Last two years with all the drama that was going on. Oh, yeah, they were kind of like in survival mode
just trying to get out of the mess, right but the problem now and the problem is
they were in survival mode when it came to advertisers and now they're in survival mode when it comes to yours users because I
Started using tick-tock and make fun of tick-tock all you want but their user base is not a joke, dude
And it's because if you're a conservative you can say whatever the hell you want to in tick-tock
IIIC conservative videos a lot of fun. I see very left-leaning videos all the time. I see shocking content all the time
There is rolls on on there, but it's not as YouTube. And so no, it's not exactly monetize to monetize the platform
They don't monetize for very many craters. I think there are some monetize creators, but it's not like anybody come on
Oh, that's the problem. The problem is not YouTube. It's the brands
They don't want their ads on that and I think it's a problem with a messaging by YouTube their failure to pitch
Correctly, I'm not saying the tic-tock will be profitable what I'm saying. Is that while the talk is going to damage the user base
It's much easier to you know
The problem is is the brand's
You're allowed to be on you and here's where I sell out one of my friends and I don't care when they hear this
They're gonna get mad, but I know a lot of people who work at Walmart
And I know people are working out or attacking Walmart II and somebody from Walmart. I won't say which person specifically
Said to me we don't really care about any of that censorship crap
We really care about any AMA. We care about lowering our beds
So we're gonna do a six-month your one year hiatus and we come back. We're gonna have much lower beds. Oh,
well, that was certainly the case when that
Pocalypse still happened that they were trying or associate but I think all of them are back now they are but they matter they came
Back at a much lower price and much lower than they've ever been. Yes
I think that they definitely use that to their advantage at the time
But I think I think like you
Mentioned EULA Suzan kind of had a good point that they were dealing with a lot internally
And I hope now that they that they can appreciate that. They need to
support
People like us because by the way, our main channel is Russia productions
we get the shit the most shit rate like the podcast and the highlights Channel makes out makes that are
like how is that possible we make premium content there that we work really hard on that we package really nicely and
Somehow it makes less money than our highlights show
Per CPM, right? Right. What the fuck is that?
Because at some point the algorithm
Decided that was a problem at channel that it's rated
pg-13 or it's rated PG 17 or something like that and because of that when one of those advertisers goes to their
Lodgings they choose I don't want to be on anything controversy
Alright, and so they their advertisers Larry will not appear on your channel meanwhile
Meanwhile, they'll still show up on a vac rap battle all the time. You know, you literally have Hitler rat battling Darth Vader, right?
Oh, that's that's fine. Right they don't curse
Yeah, or like, you know
The classic example is like the Paul brothers who were making pornography essentially for little kids. Mm-hmm
Right and you've got like a girl in the thong and the thumbnail ma'am?
It's so they need to get their shit together. Yeah, I hope they will. I mean here's the thing I criticize I
criticize the things I love I love gaming they criticize it right and
I feel like it can have an impact there and I criticize YouTube because I love it
It saved my life Susan Wojcicki and and and and and Robert Kinsel and the decisions
They have made kept me from living a life on disability of poverty
I would've able to get the surgery I would've been able to get these teeth if they had not given me the opportunities that they
have given me and God loved them and God bless them and I love everyone I've ever met at YouTube and I have nothing but
love and respect for him that said
Boy, do they need to learn how to steer the ship better? Yeah
I think there's a lot going on back there that we don't can't fully appreciate by the way meeting with her. She is
she's a really a
Thoughtful intelligent
Well-meaning lady. I mean, I mean I my impression of her was very good
And I think we all need to appreciate too that she was the one in
Google that was the biggest advocate for acquiring YouTube. That's why she's the CEO. Mmm
so
Yeah, I think I think they'll get there I think they're trying there gosh darnest yeah, I never shook her hand
I I spoke to her very briefly and
at the creator summit last year and I saw her speak of the crater summit and
You could tell how much she loves this platform how much she loves the craters how much she loves what she's doing and how desperate
She is to get it, right. Mm-hmm
and you know
I heard the fact that she has toured to see creators like you and Shane Dawson and and everyone else and it's just been incredible
to see I
Wish they cared about the small creators as much as they care about the big craters, but that's not possible
She can't meet with every small crater. She would literally be doing it for a million years, but I
Know it's at this point where I don't know if it's solvable Hank green. I love hang green
He made a video talking about platforms that might try to compete with YouTube and obviously the story fire thing we're doing
I don't think it's meant to compete with YouTube, but it's
Supplemental pretty a story for our thing
I'll tell you about what we're doing like so he's not gonna compete but it's there to supplement right like roosterteeth calm, whatever
but
If somebody did try to compete with YouTube
You literally can't because you'll have the same problems as YouTube
Right and just like you meant even worse this and and not pornography and all the miserable shit
they've been working for decades on like the legal issues that every individual country has
copyright law
Yeah
They were they were bankrolled by one of the biggest most successful companies in the world because they are only now recently actually making money
After decades, right? They're there the amount of ground they've covered is like insurmountable
Mm-hmm, and I have to say like it could be worse because it could be
Grande's book. Yeah, it could be Facebook. Thank you. Yeah, you know it could be worse
it definitely could be worse than
Maybe not exist. It could be Twitter. Yeah
God forbid right and I like Twitter. Just don't read the comments. I like Twitter
Um, just like I like sharing my life unto her, you know
I've started to get way more in the Instagram because to be honest with you
I never really Graham comments, right exactly because they're so hard to even get they're not even look, right
Yes, and it's just pictures of beautiful women and beautiful people and friends
I know doing cool stuff and it's Oh Billy. The fridge is looking great a lot of weight. Oh, let's cats
That's a great cosplay. I love this. Oh, that's my friend
The great ghoul she's really killing it these days and then I have a happy experience
People say Instagram is the most depressing experience, you know place
Well, it depends it's the happiest cuz I'm just like all these people are doing great
Well, I think if you're a young girl or even a young guy who I mean
It gets depressing because everything you see is like people at their best and you're just sitting at home
like also Photoshop beautiful women who are like, oh yeah when I hung out with
This way when I hung out with this one model who posted a lot on Instagram
I won't say her name or do I call anybody at her but hung out with her for a while and she showed me
Because I met her in real life and she's very beautiful in real life. Very beautiful real live all these women. Alright
yeah, like Liz cats or
Jessica Nigri I've met these women in real life. They're just beautiful beautiful people, right?
but um
This girl showed me how she further photo shops and further filters and showed me all these filters
you can just get on the Android store in the iPhone store and how
Vastly there's been photo that she started with and what she posted it goes and it wasn't like she was changing the shape of her
Body, cuz she didn't need to or the shape of her face
But she might put on lipstick or she might put on
Russia might put on foundation with these makeup apps or and then she would add filters to like change the coloring and change the the
focus on and make the background glory blurry
So she pops out and like whole you can do that now on them bone what planet do we?
Yeah, it just everyone has like perfect skin, you know
That's why didn't you look in the mirror? Like my skin is fair. Fuck. Why am I the only person with blackhead?
That's why I like me and ugly in public
Yeah
There's no like come look at my YouTube channel and you'll see gap-toothed morbidly
Obese big titty man and my little lake you feel good about yourself, right? Thank you. We appreciate your service
All right. Well, we're at the two-hour mark. Oh, wow, really? We black why that one
There's what could talk of all day, but we got we really come in. I love you guys. Yeah. Thank you
I love having you here Arden
three four weeks away a month can't
Believe it
That's why that's why I wanted to do it now instead of VidCon because like you're gonna be a dad
VidCon and oh, yeah, you guys think I want to talk to nobody that's actually true. We are gonna be real we're gonna yeah
We're gonna be busy. Yeah, get enjoy not sleeping for like six months though. You're staying on. Yeah, I
Can't even imagine I didn't I don't know. I still can't really believe it
Little guy in diapers and all that baby stuff. I know it
I know it's it probably sounds stupid anyone but like it starts to become so
Surreal, though that like there's a little baby. That's half me and half you
Mm-hmm, and it's like a full-grown baby. Now I can feel when every movement you can see it dude. You can see
Because I know I'm a like the same a bit of an impact
but when you first said that I saw in your smile both this
Has its hesitant hesitating worried and this wonderment and you're like he's gonna have this night person
He's gonna be a little bit you seem so happy and so scared at the same time. It was fascinating to see that look
Because I'm I don't know. It's so crazy. Yeah, I'm so I'm so proud of you guys. I'm so jealous
I never wanted kids but because you know I grew up in an abusive home
And I don't know that I could be a good dad and I just wasn't willing to risk it
I you know
I was molested and beat up and all this stuff and I I don't think I would I know I would never do anything like
That to a kid, but I don't know that I'm a good person
I don't know that the depression and the anxiety is a good environment to bring a child into
But you guys are killer I can you know
I see
From what?
Relationship I've seen on YouTube but like you guys meeting you in real life and seeing I think you guys are gonna have a wonderful
Kid, I think you guys thank you for the coffee. I hope
More like her than you yeah
Unfortunately, I feel like he's gonna look more like I feel like if you find a good relationship
Were you gonna be happy with that person? You can have it right exactly
I don't think that I have anxiety too and you have issues and everyone's got issues. Right? Right, right
We have got a problem you figure it out. Let's get shredder. You know, that's how that's how I knew
I wanted to be a parent right right that shredder I
Joke about killing myself. Are you and what do you think of your dog's I mean, but here's the thing
I mean it it's not a joke. Okay. Now that said that's a joke, but bo burnham you you interviewed bo, right? Yes
Um, I enjoyed that episode it was awkward of points, but I enjoyed boazlin walk or near a little awkward. It's awkward a point
I don't really
You way you weren't here. It was so awkward. Right, right
But he at one point and this is how I remember it
So forgive me both you ever hear this and I'm misremembering it, but I remember at some point I think on his website
He said he was born on this year and he's going to die on this year and then it was asked by a reporter
Why do you think you're gonna die that year and I think he said if I hope I'm not mister remembering this misquoting the guy
Oh, that's the year that I've done the math and that's the year than my dog will die. And that's the year
I plan to kill myself
And I thought that was just a dark joke at that point because I didn't have a dog yet
And now that I have my dog and this dog, it's the best dog in the world. I love still we literally know
Yes
Here's the thing. Whoever thinks they have the best dog in the world
They're right. Cuz all dogs are the best don't I wrong I ever met a right dog. You're wrong
but Sammy God loved him the best thing my ex-wife ever did for me and she literally saved my Walt life is
She said even though every time we ever talked about sweating
She's like and I'm taking the dog cause he's my dog when we finally split
She's like you should keep the dog and because she decided to do that
During the darkest points to Christmas after the divorce no matter how miserable I was
Furry little bastards like this thing right here. Look at this. Look at this. Be careful red
It's gonna make fun of you. Let them KITT lick your face. Oh my god. You're so gross. Oh, no, but but little
Monsters like this. I made it through those darkest points and that dog is so addicted to me now
24 hours a day
We're physically in constant just like when you stepped out just a few minutes ago and shredder followed you no matter where you're going
Sammy's exactly. I literally leaned forward in the chair and seems like what we're going. What are we doing?
He's the most loyal dog. And it's wild because when I got him it was a shitty dog was he he he grew up
I guess with in a home with three other animals and that made him miserable and
When he came to the house, he was pissing all over the place
He was shitting all over the place if he tried to pick him up
He would bite you he would run from you and we had to just completely change this, baby
But within six months I had him. Okay playing in my arms
I had him laying in my arms eating treats in my lap and
The what a triumph right? And so now when I'm gone for five days, he's just the most depressed dog
And I'm depressed without him it really but when I'm at home, we were within physical contact 24 hours a day
I learned to take a bath. That's the only time he can't touch me
So he's in a he's laying next to the tub. Does that we're dead?
He's laying next to me touching me if I'm filming for YouTube my dog 90% of the time
He's laying on a stool next to me with his butt touching my leg napping
Yeah, unless he has to get up to go out or something there. So pure I say I always say to Gila
I
wasn't sure about
I'm not a yeah, he prefers to drink are
There angels, they are truly angels on this planet we don't deserve dogma and I've
You've seen Ricky Gervais is no serious afterlife so much. It's waiting. Good get a new
Afterlife Oh his show
I'm sin, but I will tell you that's how it starts is his wife dies from cancer
and he's super depressed and he he wants to kill himself basically, but then the dog comes in and
looks at him like he's hungry or something and he's like
It's so funny because I actually tweeted to Ricky Gervais to tell him
what he showed in that show is
Almost exactly what I experienced after my divorce because I kind of turned into an asshole
you can see clips of me being an asshole on the internet because I was being an ass on there cuz I was hurt and
I was miserable and I'm suffering and I was depressed and he didn't want to be there
I don't want to do anything and I was just so unhappy and
What he was going through with the suicidal thoughts and then and the ideology and I didn't use heroin or anything like that
But I I did some really stupid self-destructive stuff because I was just so unhappy
and to see him make it through that show and
I just gone through that entire process and was about where the character is at the end of that show
I was like that couldn't have been more real like that. If you haven't watched that on Netflix, you have to watch it
Did you also think oh you did. Yeah, I didn't know but you watch that
very fast just
Like you watched everything on Netflix. It's like in one day I
Tried to stretch it out to I was like I want to watch one episode of that because his other series on Netflix
Derek if you've seen that know
It's he plays like a mentally challenged mentally challenged to do two works at like an old folks home and you will cry
Every episode with me. Yeah. It's like mentally challenged a missile. Yeah, and he does it really well
It plays like a mentally challenged dude car Lincoln turns in the show, right? Yeah, and it's a drama. It's a dramedy. I would say
Because it is funny it parts and definitely has some comic relief
But you will cry every episode if you watch the video and you don't write once that you are not a human
You are dead inside that guy something else man. He's a real juggernaut. Yeah, I live nothing but love and respect for that, dude
I I would take a bullet for that guy. He's easily you want a better comedian. I think so, man
He's it's not just he's a good comedian
But it's just that he's using his power to tell very real stories
No one else is telling I wonder if you would ever be in a situation and take a bullet probably not
That's why I say it right ever was in that situation. You're like a defeated shakiness your hand and then someone
It's like slow motion and then you like recall this conversation, but you guys have to remember I'm self-destructive
Anyway, I warned you and you're looking for
Somebody stab me. Yeah every time you meet someone say nice to meet you and take a bullet for you
Yeah, I'm the bullet I'm the bull again I'm fat I can take four or five men through this this party
You know
I I saw episode of cops where a fat guy got stabbed and
He was totally fine because he there was so much fat you break. It didn't even come close to
Admitting his life. I thought I have a member. I have a memory one time being fatty. I had a vivid memory of that
I was like wow
Being fat saved this man's life. Hmm and what I was useful
yeah, I wonder if I wonder if there's more we haven't yet thought of
You float really? Well, so if you're really
Really hard to get to the bottom of the water when I was like 400 pounds or so
Is it easy for you to lay back and just be really right?
So have you ever got like in the ocean? We wouldn't even it'll flight jacket man. Really? He's way for rescues
We like chillin till shark comes up and bite you see you, but you're so fat
He's just gonna take a little bit of you right been feeling like I just want to go in and pull
Know that I'm like, oh, it's gonna be have you not done it
Are you doing like I wanna okay
Can I really probably you're gonna like natural childbirth or like water birth or clear water? Birth is like amazing. What do you think?
they're doing
regular
Hospital
Epidural if your regular shit, right you have any pain or anything get into some battery? It's so useful because
My back hurts. I'm so sorry. Have you heard of a skydiving birth?
Is that where you pull the cord and then like jerks
Redis the hex crowning you jump out but the doctor and you have about you know, five minutes or so, so it
It increases the intensity and you just you really get it done
Cuz you don't want to hit that ground you don't hit that ground when the baby's not out all the way
Or maybe you do maybe
Maybe if you're in Texas and just can't give an abortion any other way
Alrighty
What do you got for the rest of LA? Um
This Is It this is a the last thing I wanted to do I did a
Universal and walked off a mile and did all bunch of rides. I couldn't fit on every ride, but I'm fed
Almost and did you do the Harry Potter? I could not fit on
But I did have a
butterbeer and Mountain Dew can fuck right off because that was amazing that I had a butterbeer and I was like
Oh my god, this shit is so dirty. Yeah, I couldn't finish it, but it was like
And it's just like a mega cream soda, right
I had launched it like the Three Broomsticks and then the the studio tour which is the real reason
I was there I can about yeah, and then did the walking dead experience twice cuz
Amazing it was terrifying because I don't get what they've done was about the walking dead
The last three seasons since like negan hit that one guy in the head. I'm just like done, right?
but
The walking dead experience was terrifying they love haunted houses, man
I'm coming back for I think in October to come to Knott's Scary Farm
Just just to do that because I love that scary show. Well, you got to keep you got to get on Harry Potter
That's when you know, right right, right
How do they measure you how do they there so there's a little measurement a little you know
Test seat or whatever and she's like you're so close honey. Can you just pull your stomach in? I'm like no
Because I could have probably pulled my stomach in to fit the rest of the way
But they don't have to ride a ride like that Yeah, right
I think I would have I didn't had no interest in on the wooden rollercoaster. I think I would have fit on that one
Yes, did him again. Yeah
But I felt when everything else wanted to do so, that's awesome
The Simpson ride was really good for such an old ride to I was like a really awesome smart
yeah, but oh I do it was like a
car, yeah
But Disney I was able to do I did Disney in December, um
Took my friend mcjuggernuggets and Adam the whoo. He's a great creator. If you don't know, I don't look him up on
YouTube he's amazing. He literally does Disneyland for a living that's literally a job because the theme parks for a job. It's amazing
well
so is that YouTube he just literally goes in films like rides and films like
Doesn't like a new Shaq opens it at Universal. He goes in films the experience and then shares it with everybody
He's been doing it for like how do you not run out of content?
Because there's always something changing at Disneyland always something and he gets a lot of views. It's
Enough. I mean he gets like 25 30,000 views per video and then eventually like everyone's wrong to get a viral is too much viral
videos he went into the backstage of F cought Center like where stuff was shut down and filmed once and
Then another time he went to Universal Studios, Florida and the old Nickelodeon soundstage
He filmed the urban decay of the old
Nickelodeon soundstage and solves like some of the old stuff were like Ren and Stimpy are still on the wall and those videos got millions
Of millions of views and really made his name. But so that's what he does for a living
He goes to theme parks and explores the country and films kölsch it and it was love I watched every episode I had for three
years, um, though we went to
Disney and I rode my first roller coaster since I was fifteen it was doing credit coaster
I wrote them all the in credit credit coasters. The only that one item lights. Yeah, it was Tara one
That one is really and it was in that was the first experience right? That was actually it was amazing
Yeah, I have an anxiety. So I mostly just screamed the whole time cuz I lost complete control
Yeah, and then we did both parks we did
Distant California, the only thing I regret doing was the guardians of Galaxy ride. Fuck whoever engineered that love that I hated
Your man tits choking you as you okay. That's the difference, right?
I literally literally had my gut wrap around my head like I needed to be cut out. That's how bad it was
Look at actual footage or an Adam's
You know me doing the all these rights and when we were doing the guardians of the galaxy one
You can already see my tits left. I know it's
Because it's you fall faster than gravity. It's yeah faster than gravity. Yeah, that's insane, right?
That's the only one I regret but Space Mountain was also a hell of an experience because it's a dark roller
Don't like the dark and I don't like roller coaster
so I I did use my my pain reliever to get through VidCon that day and I was probably a little
Little buzzed by the time we got the Space Mountain and I'm glad I was on it because I passed out on Space Mountain
Like in the queue I passed out at one point and I played it off like I was just setting down
I knew that I passed out right?
But like are you sure?
Yeah enough from like exhaustion sidewalk like seven and half miles that day right like if my body wasn't ready for example imagine
Yeah, we gotta get you like a disney season past and just get you out there
Hell, yeah, right like or even just moving to a city
Because the walk I like this morning, I got up and walked three and a half lakhs just for fun right now
Who cares right like I actually have places, you know
Yeah makes exactly I was in New York man. I was walking so much. Yeah, because it's just it's naturals party
Do you ever miss New York? Um, not really I like LA a lot. I
Like I mean New York's really fun to visit, but overall. I think LA's is such a fantastic place
I really like it because John was always the New York boy, right?
You know and then he's moved to the edge of New York. Well, he's in New Jersey now
Okay, John, right John so funny he goes he he'll be he's the New York boy and then all the sudden one day
He's like I hate New York right now that may be always of a Newark and he's like I never said that
No, but he's in New York, he's in New Jersey he loves it she still loves it my kids he's I think I
Need to watch more case maybe
Well, I know he didn't tell me not to say anything Yeah, right, he told me he's moving LA yeah, that's cool man
But John Johnson to him great, he's fucking killed. I know that I'm Rooney for like three videos up in the last month Dolph
I know he's out. He's out uploading me
not that that's a feed these days but I mean
And plus I'm like your videos are good. I really like know what's coming. I love what you've been uploading but mine. Yeah
Yeah, I was I was making the joke that Jon's countenance better than yours. Yeah, but it's not a joke
So no, it's not
No, he put so much work into I the one time I got to hang out with John or life. Wait. Was it a joke?
No, it's not at all John's content. It's amazing. It's like better than mine
It's better than anybody's do know but it's usually it's better than fucking anybody
seriously
Like one time I talked to John the one time I thought your honor hung out with him at VidCon and it's like buddy
I want to quit YouTube and like yukia says that every night it goes. It's just so hard
and I know it doesn't have to be hard John you make it hard on yourself because
Every video has to be better than the last video and we know it doesn't I would watch you complain about
Donkey Kong in your bedroom again just make that please make that thank know there has to be good
In capably is neurotic
Actually neuroses, right?
Yeah
I feel bad for the guy but know her because it's the videos or oh well better than last
I think what he needed is a really good team support system what she has he's in a really healthy
Relationship with a really great girl. Yeah, and he's just got everything great and he seems like mentally he's in a good place
he's got a good team around him and
So I think he's just a healthier place and to be creative. You know, I'm trying to build now for myself, right?
I don't think I'll ever meet the girl. I've given up on that but I've got like I hired my first uh
I hired my team to do my little crappy podcast and a little gaming podcast
Nobody listens to I was really doing that to try to build their careers
and then
Hired my roommate who was working custodial at the you know
The hyper building and doing mowing lawns and crap
hired him on as my PA and and now I have like an actual team and and then we're I'm
Gearing up to hire to do this story fire creation stuff the content there with Francis to film in that gaming store
I bought and like get some actual actors to make an actual narrative to help actual story and
yeah, I feel like really creative for the first time in a while and I felt like I'm sticking to my creative integrity and and
Yeah, I'm gonna like really good place. Not that I think if most people were in the place of it right now
They would be like, wow, it's hard being you you're suicidal and miserable and I'm like, yes
But it's also the best I've ever been. This is the happiest I've ever been including the whole time
I was married including my first year of upper-bound including
Yeah, I just I don't know. I feel like I feel like I'm taking on the world
Well, let's keep it going, you know. Yeah, let's keep that predict. Turi going. Let's see you in a year
Let's get you on that Harry Potter ride. Oh, yeah, and
I'm always looking forward to Boogie's next visit. Oh, yeah. Well, I'll see you in exactly one year. Yeah one year
Yeah, and I'll have a one-year-old shave. I know that's right. He doesn't exist yet, but he will next year. Mm-hmm
It's wild man. You made life. Yeah, I know and that life is going to affect the world. Do you think about that, right?
Let's so what we're all doing as creators, right? We're trying to affect the world a little bit either
It's just entertain people to make them happier or whatever
But you're putting real life in the world that life could cure cancer one day. It's not design
Now he's gonna be great he's gonna be a cool dude, but if he's anything like I mean if he's like me
He's not curing cancer. He might get really good at fortnight three now. We're talking now. We've got expectations in the right place now
It's not like Pro, but like pretty good right like pretty good. Yeah, a guy win like one. Oh,
Yeah
Yeah, my dream is to get rich enough so that he just
will never have to work and he can play for tonight all day a
Real trust on baby right you ever see a key and peele has a sketch about Will Smith's son Jaden
No, all right
And it's like super funny sketching is one of my favorites
But Jaden is like reading a script right and he's like trying to relate to this
I was talking to this agent in this agents like yeah, so this this he's plays basketball and it goes right
So where does he play the basketball? He's like outside. It's like
In the hallway and he's like no no outside. He's like in the garage. He's like no no
Outside. Well, what is outside outside? Is that area? Like when you get into your limo, it's the stuff you drive through
and he's like, oh
Why would you play ball out there?
This is like one of those like you imagine raising the key. That's so completely
Desensitized as Jane Smith as to what reality like her first theater. That's what I want for my dog. Yeah
Yeah, that's kind of the joy about dogs
You can spoil them like you can and I do so bad like in order to find
because he was addicted to human food when we got him and he was
Underweight because they wouldn't feed him very often. He so I had to buy one of
every treat mmm that existed on Amazon to find three that he liked yeah and now
To feed him those three. He only eats part of them
There's this one called goofballs in it's a white rawhide ball, but there's a little red chicken script that runs through it
He'll piece out the chicken strip and then throw away the rawhide they come out so like a buck a ball
So he's even like for a day. Yeah, I'm spending four bucks a day on one of the treats but who gives a shit?
Yeah, he's my dog. He did I will starve before that dog will do without a a goofball
Yeah, we got to get him that we gotta get goofballs stat. Mm-hmm. All right. We'll see you in a year Q ma'am
We wish you well, we wish you all the best. We wish you a happy
'no sand joy stay out of the comment saying yourself. I'm not even checking Twitter for the layout Leon. Just do it
Just do it do a check and then give yourself a week and after the week B just check in with yourself
See how you're doing. Here's what I will say. Let me close with this. Okay, if anything I have said in this podcast
Has been stupid if anything I've said on the Internet has been stupid
I won't even though I have nothing but the best of intentions the only thing I want is for the people listening right now
To have love and prosperity and and find some happiness in their life. And if you're unhappy with me
Screw me. It's ignore me forget I exist and go find something that makes you happy man
Don't spend your time tearing me down spend your time building yourself up. That's all I've ever tried to do for me
I was trying to never tear anybody down Tim Sweeney maybe from time to time but for the most part
I'm just trying to build my life up. Please. Let me do that
And and why don't you guys go do that for yourselves? Right? I get it I suck
Sometimes I've really screwed up and I've tried to make up for it. I'm trying to be a better person
I'm trying to put
positivity in the world and I'm trying to help people whether it's get their teeth done or come play in my game store or
Whatever man and and I hope you choose to do the same put the same effort
You would put into tearing me or Ethan or ela or little teddy or shredder down little teddy
Yeah, you know I've been in the world people are sitting on hell write
It use that same effort to build your life out and and let's make this place a better place man. Hey, let's make
The for door. Yeah, great again. Yeah. Thank you for that
Beautiful. I already hear you troll ass bitches
fucking hater ass
Cocksuckers you cooks get a fucking life in other words, right?
And I will not get I do you a
Motherfucking losers. Yes. That's how I feel to get a life
All right, guys
Hope you have a terrific weekend. Thank you as always for watching we love and appreciate you. H3 army
We're going to war every episode here on the h3 pot. Yes, we are going to war
Thanks for watching
I love you very much and I'll speak with you again soon sons of bitches you fucking boxing cock
Get off already go find a girl. Yeah